So Leute ich bin auch mal wieder am Start, Quality Options sind auch da, sehr nice,
da hört es vielleicht ein bisschen, ich bin erkältet, ich habe die letzten 3 Tage im
Bett gelegen und habe mir jetzt irgendwann gedacht, ich habe keinen Bock mehr im Bett
zu legen, vielleicht soll ich das erstmal, vielleicht soll ich warten bis überhaupt
ein paar Leute im Stream sind bevor ich das erzähle, Omega Lul, Hyper Lul, gibts denn
danach, Lul, Hyper Lul, Omega Lul, was könnte man da noch machen, Extreme Lul, Omega Hyper
Lul, keine Ahnung, ich bin heute nicht so kreativ was das angeht, naja, naja, naja,
ok, was hat mir da einer für Link geschickt?
Ich mache ungern Links auf wo ich nicht weiß, was dahinter ist, ach ne Risen Test, da brauchen
wir nicht.
Aber was hab ich eigentlich für eine Kategorie eingestellt? Vom Stremen, was hab ich für eine
Kategorie eingestellt? Hallo Hexoha, der Danny ist am Start, der Hydrogen Jojo. Ich seh nicht
was ich für eine Kategorie eingestellt hab. Chatting wahrscheinlich, oder? Kann doch
nicht sein, dass ich meine eigene Kategorie vom Stremen nicht sehe. Geil, sieht man nicht,
nice. Good Job Frisch, gut gemacht. Aber wenn ich hier suche, dann find ich's wahrscheinlich.
Ich kann ja mal schreiben. Ihr hört's wahrscheinlich, ich bin auch ein bisschen krank. Was hat er
eingestellt? Just Chatting. MonkaSick bin ich heute. Gibt's sowas? MonkaSick? Nein, nicht
Maps, Alter, nicht Maps. Okay, was auch immer das mit MonkaSick zu tun hat. Aber gibt's
auch nicht. Ich bin gerade recht MonkaSick, ja. Ich war schon ewig keine Erkältung mehr.
Scheiß irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Jahr oder so, irgendwie ewig nicht mehr. Opera hat
einen Gaming Browser, hab ich noch nicht gesehen, hier kann man's gleich angucken. Die Chinesen
sind das ja. Opera ist ja nicht, was waren die früher? Schweden? Nee, also mittlerweile
ist es ja Chinesen. China. China All You Can Eat Browser. Einen Opera Gaming Browser,
also ernsthaft, ja. Ist doch schon monologisches. Opera GX, was es nicht alles gibt. Der erste
Gaming Browser. Okay, und was, also was mir schon mal echt auf den Sack geht, ist, dass
die Webseite nicht funktioniert. Man kann nicht scrollen. Also man kann scrollen, aber
es ist MonkaHuge langsam. Hört ihr mich scrollen hier? Aber es passiert nichts. Also die Webseite
ist schon mal übelster Bullshit. Fyltasten, Bild hoch, Bild runter geht nicht, Fyltasten
nicht richtig also die website ist huge crap also ich habe schon eigentlich schon
wieder keinen Bock mehr anzugucken wenn die Webseiten nicht richtig ok was was kann denn der
Gaming Browser was was kann der da schon geil das war Tyler55
Alter das kann doch nicht sein das nicht mal das nicht mal Tasten funktionieren auch so
nach kacke sei das ist so ein typischer fall von javascript fail man muss alles in javascript
neu machen was eigentlich schon wunderbar da ist und funktioniert
OPERA GX GAMING BROWSER ok wofür braucht man das jetzt der erste gaming browser
ich mach mal ein stückchen größer der erste gaming browser
OPERA GX ist eine besondere version des OPERA Browsers also im Prinzip eine besondere
variante von chrome die wurde speziell als gaming ergänzung
entwickelt aha ok also bis jetzt ist eigentlich nur marketing bla bla
ok was was kann es dann zeig mal video erstmal was ist das für eine sei was ist das für
eine sa ernsthaft ok ich will mir die bewertung angucken das ist ich hasse so
jebaiting seiten guck und klickt das das ist übelstarker du klickst das an und denkst
so ha ich klicke jetzt auf die titelleiste nein machst du nicht klickst nicht auf die
titelleiste weil bäm ok also youtube bewertungen sind schon mal nicht
sonderlich viele ok es ist stylische auf neu gemachte gaming musik die muss
natürlich sein was ok moment jetzt muss ich mir noch mal angucken
gaming browser behalte die kontrolle ja vor allem wenn es in china browser ist
da behalte ich voll krass die kontrolle ist wahnsinn wie ich da die kontrolle
memory und cpu nutzung einschränken seitdem es jetzt modern ist das browser
irgendwie 6 gigabyte brauchen jetzt kann was einschränken das problem ist doch
wenn man die memory benutzung von einem browser einschränkt also der verbraucher
nicht auch spaß an der freude so viel so viel speicher dann kacken wir entweder
deine tabs ab du kannst keine tabs mal aufmachen oder sonst war es es läuft
nicht richtig also leute vielleicht ein bisschen ich bin immer noch monka zig
deswegen war ich die letzten tage auch nicht ordentlich habe jetzt ich habe
jetzt dienstag im bett gelegen mittwoch im bett gelingen also ich bin am pc
gesessen aber das war es zum großen und ganzen dienstag mittwoch donnerstag jetzt
bis bis eben das ist irgendwie so 1530 da habe ich mir gedacht ich kann nicht die
ganze zeit immer rumliegen ich mache mal streben an ich weiß nicht wie lange ich
das durchhalte mit streben heute weil mir läuft immer noch ein bisschen die nass
und ich kenne das ja wenn man am rechner sitzt da fange ich irgendwann auch die
augen an zu drehen dann muss ich ausmachen ich könnte jetzt aber mal was richtig
tolles feature von meiner klimaanlage verwenden und zwar kann man die
klimaanlage einstellen auf durchzug also dann lüfte die klimaanlage nur und
frische luft ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt wenn man strebt ich meine man
könnte auch das fenster aufmachen das ist aber nicht so das fenster aufmachen
ist wirklich absoluter noob style 2019
machen wir mal an
komplett overrated fenster aufmachen nicht sei doch grund warum ich aufmache
einfach weil autos züge sonst was muss ich unbedingt sein im hintergrund gibt es
auch gaming fenster sollte man vielleicht mal erfinden ja mit rgb also
standardmäßig rgb trille dann wie wie so eine so eine optics brillen mit gelb
filter braucht muss also wisst ihr man braucht das wie so eine wie heißen die
dinger wie heißen die optics ich habe auch so ein teil ich habe vergessen was
heißt gerne optics gar optics prille so so eine prille bräuchte das also sprich
das gaming fenster hätte dann auch so einen gelb filter dass der kontrast
größer ist draußen weil ich mein für die richtigen quickscopes muss man doch
schon mal sehen ja ok komm jetzt mal an was du als opera noch uns erzählt zum
browser hallo ich würde es gerne größer machen
moin daniel aus österreich ok zeige ja memory und cpu nutzung einschränken
ja gut wenn es sein muss ich meine die idee ist nicht verkehrt aber man könnte
also es besteht die möglichkeit dass wenn der browser einfach zu viel ram
verwenden dass man paar tabs zu macht also ich weiß das ist ein konzept das
verstehen vielleicht manche leute nicht dass wenn man weniger tabs hat das ding
weniger ram braucht aber sonderlicher big brain move ist das jetzt nicht ein
paar tabs zuzumachen egal nicht nicht es muss man muss es ja nicht alle so
negativ sehen vielleicht ist gar nicht schlecht das probieren wir mal aus das
ding gleich wir machen gleich mal unsere win aus vm an weil auf meinem auf meinem
desktop pc installiere ich den china crap nicht das probieren wir uns gleich mal in
der vm an der opera gaming browser
keinen livestream heute gab es da noch irgendwas ich bin heute nicht so schnell
im kopf ja
memory und cpu nur zu verpassen keinen livestream mehr verpassen twitch discord
ist da ist also so ist da quasi so betta twitch tv integriert also das ist
eigentlich ist das ganz cool ja
eigentlich ist das ganz nice ich meine es gibt es bestimmt auch als chrome
plugin
das gibt es garantiert schon als plugin irgendwo so eine twitch seitenleiste
aber an sich finde ich die idee nicht nicht blöde
hä wo was ist jetzt der wahnsinn man kann sich streams angucken ok
aber die einfach nur so wer zum teufel ist nix wer ist wer ist gx marco und
warum hat der typ 92.000 zuschauer wer ist das
gx marco hast du nie gehört du bist das hier
die beide den gibt es überhaupt nicht
chinesen photoshop skills am start die chinesen photoshop skills sind da ich
meine die zahlen sind auch ein bisschen unrealistisch ne erstens war so ein
typ mit so einem default bildchen dann irgendwie nur so für so wenige
follower für 92.000 zuschauer und moment moment was wie viele views hat
der typ millionen milliarden eine milliarde 135.000.000 48.000 563 views
absolut easy das kriegen wir nächsten monat haben wir das auch
guck mal weiter videos im video pop out weiter streamen das geht doch jetzt auch
schon kann mir das einer mit chinesen opera ist in chinesen in das gehört
blablabla 2000 2016 90 prozent blablabla opera software an das chinesische
konsum golden pricks hat er jetzt hat er wie eine minecraft gilde oder golden
brick sehr alles das minecraft klaren machen
silkro ich sehe gott nicht diese komische skamars bitcoin börse gewesen
oder bring ich das jetzt das klingt das klingt schon wieder alles so so
dubios der name von dem zeug zumindest opera gehört chinesen deswegen ich
mache mich jetzt hier irgendwie nicht lustig und es ist fack dass die chinesen
sind
genau und richtig plutonian plutonian hat recht der alte oder die alte
alten entwickler teilweise zumindest an die da in darknet shop war das das
stimmt keine bitcoin mehr stimmt ja irgendwie so die arbeiten jetzt an wie
waldi und wie waldi ist eigentlich relativ cool der browser
videos in videos pop out das das geht jetzt teilweise auch schon und wenn
sie der browser nicht kann zumindest auf twitch kamers mit mit pranker faces z
und bei der twitch tv und so kann man das kann man das machen ich weiß gar nicht
ob's twitch standardmäßig schon kann
game den neugigkeiten und deals verfolgen brauche ich jetzt net
hast einen problem und sehe ich das richtig der browser hat eine rgb steuerung
richtig rgb oder ist das nur die optik nee das ist sogar ok komm mal nur zurück
das ist nur die optik vom browser ich dachte irgendwie das ist der rgb steuerung
im browser drin das ist gar nicht rgb das ist einfach nur browser wie der
browser aussieht das ist gar nicht so gar nicht so toll wie ich gedacht habe
limited edition hintergründe da sie bestimmt furchtbar limited wenn ich
jeder runterladen kann oder das ist ernst gemeint das ist der operati x
gaming browser
aber tut mal
um ist der huste was also leute für für alle jetzt extrem reingekommen ich
glaube man hört so ein bisschen ich bin immer noch monka sik aber ein std
mittwoch donnerstag ist quasi bis die ganze zeit im bett gelesen ein bisschen
am rechner gesetzt durch ich habe jetzt keinen bock mehr gehabt rumzulegen
außerdem geht schon ein bisschen besser deswegen habe ich jetzt gleich mal
streben an man kommt der browser da ist der ist schon
raus kontrolliere deine privaten vpn moment moment
das muss man jetzt mal genau angucken wozu war was was zum geier braucht man
einen dedizierten gaming browser für rgb beleuchtung steuern
frako perra keine fass weiß ich
kostenlos ist das china vpn ist das china vpn will ich wirklich meinen
kompletten traffic über china vpn leiten ja das ist das will ich das echt
machen das ist wahrscheinlich eher so was in der
richtung wenn ich auf irgendwelche seiten nicht zugreifen kann da mache ich
mal schnell vor pn an
optimal location ja da kann es dann wahrscheinlich auswählen scheng sheng
123 oder so das probieren wir aus wollen wir das ausprobieren
ich habe noch die windows vm vom letzten war wir können den gaming browser mal
ausprobieren in der virtual location ist was ich gemeint wurde ein ausgangspunkt
ist also wo du rauskommst im vpn also wie es nach außen hin aussieht von wo du
kommst
also im prinzip obsieren server bei foxconn nehmen oder bei express oder
ne keine an wir gucken uns das gleich mal an in der vm blockiere werbung mit dem ist auch nichts
neues ich meine es ist nicht so als wäre brauche
man da für den gaming browser chatte über die integrierten
wozu das kann übrigens firefox auch firefox hat seit ein paar versionen hat
das in den chat drinne ich habe noch nicht eine seite gesehen und nicht einen
nutzer der den firefox chat verwendet firefox hat seit irgendwie fünf versionen
aus und chat eingebaut verwendet keine sau keine sau ist noch zu viel keiner
ist der leere beliebte erweiterung hier wahrscheinlich einfach kaum erweiterung
jetzt runterladen
ok ich habe jetzt nicht so genau erkannt wozu ich
downloaded and man that's what we gamers needed new main browser sieht
überhaupt nicht nach fake kommen aus der perfekte browser jetzt in einer noch
perfekteren gx version einfacher ja legit comments legit sehr legit ja ist
überhaupt nicht von den selber pretty cool musiktat
das des braus supports my flow
ich weiß nicht was bei ihm genau wo wohin fließt aber ich weiß nicht was
mein flow ist jetzt opera feature kennen ja ich habe ich ok das probieren wir
jetzt mal aus das ding das heißt eigentlich überhaupt nicht das was ich
im stream machen wollte aber ihr wisst ja sei track fps beste
machen wir mal unsere unsere windows vm an und installieren uns den den opera
gaming browser also ich installiere absichtlich in der vm weil ich will den
nicht auf meinem desktop installieren zu viel
warum ist mein netzwerk neu mein netzwerk ist überhaupt nicht neu
no also immer
ok opera gx
der gaming browser beat prod fragt mal ein wenig auf topic welches tool würdest
du eigentlich empfehlen wenn man auf einem windows 10 dns over tls dns sehr
kammel ehrlich gesagt kaltblasen schimmer was ist
windows dns tools gibt also unter linux verwende ich eigentlich fast immer dns
mask wenn es einfach sein muss dns mask ist quasi idioten sicher und kann
oder weniger alles was man so braucht
und wenn ich den dns will der alles kann nämlich bein wobei wobei bein so viel
kann dass man keiner bein kann ist dem ich mein
das ist auch geil du gehst mit dem firefox auf eine seite um um den anderen
browser runter zu laden und das erste was du als hinweis kriegst im firefox
ist new in firefox content blocken ja da lasst doch gleich noch blocken
ok safe hier installieren wir uns das jetzt war
ok sie haben schon mal einen stylischen installer
stylische installer options also wenn ich zwischendurch mal mute oder so nicht
wundern am schusen oder irgendwas hast du wenigst auch noch nicht aber ich habe
das
was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen aber ich habe das letzten satz wieder
gesehen die gaming stromgeschichte language englisch install blar
warte mal wartet mal leute wisst ihr was wir machen bevor wir uns den den
gaming browser installieren installieren wir uns den process explorer und gucken mal was
der was der so macht der gaming browser vielleicht sehen wir schon im
hintergrund irgendwas warum wir das vielleicht eher nicht
now run sysinternals live einfach andere seite oder was
run yes ja ja wie ein green alles gut hier nach cpu cpu ok installieren wir mal
weiter help improve by sending nein default browser
nein install war ist bestimmt ein elektron installer oder
das ist bestimmt elektron installer irgendwas in der richtung was das
oh es ist schwarz da ist er der opera gaming browser ok und ok und jetzt
er ist vorhanden er ist transparent und er kennt kaum was
okay gucken wir uns die geile twitch unterstützung an go to twitch
aber muss ich muss ich einloggen ok das ok das ist auch logisch irgendwie wenn
das personalisiert channels anzeigen soll und so was heute kommt was zu modern
warfare ja ich weiß nicht ob ich so lange durchhalte wie gesagt bin immer
noch mr. monka sik also mir läuft immer noch ein bisschen die nass
vielleicht wenn ich bis 19 uhr durchhalte gibt es ein event um 19 uhr
gibt es den modern warfare event wo man zum ersten mal wohl live den den
was konnte in 2 2 was ist zwei competitive multiplayer was passiert
wenn du recht wahrscheinlich favorites seite also das sieht alles nicht so ganz
richtig aus irgendwie oder ich mein immer mal auf reddit so
hallo ich da das sieht ein bisschen kaputt aus
so ein bisschen bisschen schlecht lesbar
das ist ein bisschen schlecht lesbar vielleicht ist es einfach nur für
dachs für dachs teams ausgelegt ja richtig krasse gämmer dachs teams ja
und und warum warum genau habe ich 21 prime loot ich bin nicht mal
eingeloggt warum habe ich prime loot das ist tibet oder das ist huge tibet
ist das einfach webkit oder eine eigene angel das ist wahrscheinlich chromium
oder nie wie heißt jetzt blink blink nee doch oder blink ist das neue das ist
wahrscheinlich in chrome fork alle alle ganzen chromium chrome chromium zeug
ziemlich sicher können wir uns auch gleich können wir gleich überprüfen
nehmen wir einfach nach add-ons gucken
ok das ist mein krasser prime looter auf mich wartet also ok was was was was
konnte man auch schönes machen ja hier rgb ane nicht rgb transparent sieht
alles ein bisschen ein bisschen fail aus irgendwie mit dem all
change lock
27 tage für neue browser bis sie lange mit updates ok also war was haben sie
jetzt hier noch schönes angebieten das kann doch kein mensch lesen
das ist das hier oben ist auch eindeutig das ist oder ist das firefox
ok add-ons wie installiert man add-ons
ist blink ok wie installiert man add-ons
alle leute hier also ich sag euch wenn man geld ist vorm rechner sind scheiße
aber ich kann nicht ganz an den bett legen ist auch kacke
add-on hier extend und ja das ist das ist das in chrome
das ist
das sind das sind chrome ich vermute mal dass es wirklich chrome sind man
erkennt sich so richtig aber halt gefiltert bei was da drin was in diesem
operashop erscheint ok ehrlich gesagt so genau den vorteil vom krassen gaming
browser sehe ich jetzt persönlich nicht
aber vielleicht ihr ja
wachsteuerung f und jetzt
stimmt genau erkenn ich ehrlich gesagt nicht das könnte auch ein firefox sein
stimmt wo kann man jetzt das ram limit wo kommt man das ram limit machen ja hier
irgendwo wenn man sehen würde ok der browser ist nicht zu verwenden
und ich muss über die rote taschentücher holen wartet mal kurz
ok wir haben start
ja wo macht man jetzt das ram wo stellt man den ram in ram ein ich vermute ja mal
hier irgendwo oder aber da oh man sieht was man braucht ein tag sieben dann
sieht man was ok help about about
also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass das denn chrome ist aber so richtig also
es ist das ding schreit irgendwie voll nach chrome ja
das sieht auch nach chrome aus aber so richtig ja auch die versionsnummer sieht
sehr nach chrome aus
aber auf der anderen seite es hat auch gewissen gewisses feeling von von
firefox irgendwie kann man ich kann man hier mit user agent oder so irgendwie
auslesen was erst google geht nur im chrome ernsthaft quatsch das geht doch
auch ach das ist das neue oder das kann aber sein dass es hier nicht funktioniert
falls eine vms browser identifikation mozilla stand da wo
what is my user agent da gibt es auch bestimmt eine seite die das anzeigen
hier mozilla das ist das ist ne wat ich bin alles auf einmal mein user agent ist
mozilla apple webkit chrome ist das normal
sind die echt so aus ich hab das schon ewig da mal angeguckt
nä so so sieht das ist so sieht denn ordentlicher user agent aus bei der
kennt es ist ein firefox so und im also das geht nur auf google
okay was warum warum sehen user agents mittlerweile so merkwürdig aus warum
steht in dem user agent nicht drin was der user agent ist
okay darf man jetzt da rein interpretieren weil das 64 dass der
weil das mozilla vorne steht dass das irgendwie nen gecko basis ist privacy
ah verstehe ist eigentlich ganz ganz clever ja also eigentlich eigentlich
verständlich da kann man keine profile anfertigen von vom browser
aber auch das hier das sieht irgendwie schon ein bisschen nach chrome aus
wie aber mal ganz davon abgesehen es ist eigentlich vollkommen egal was es unter
der haube ist ja das ist auf jeden fall dass das das das sieht so chrome mäßig
aus install chrome extensions ja gut also ganz ehrlich wenn es den addon gibt
install chrome extensions dann wird das dann wird es ja eigentlich die chrome
totter sein das ist das auf jeden fall dann ist das dann ist das chrome oder
chromium oder blink oder was auch immer ja gut haben wir das haben wir das
geklärt einmal ganz davon abgesehen also wirklich sinnvoll erscheint mir das
ganze nicht ok wo stellt man jetzt ein diese ram ram belegungen geschichte
extensions downloads history page settings das icon über twitch
ach da gx control ok das geht nur auf der dunklen seite das ui ist busy kaputt
ja was man sagen limit how much ram opera kann use
ach du ach mist ich wollte mal ganz runter stellen hat limit bem how much cpu
can use 15 mal gucken mal gucken wie gut das jetzt läuft gleich speichert
automatisch wahrscheinlich alles stimmt die seite geht ja nicht wenn man
moment die cpu war gerade 35 das geht doch gar nicht limit ja was soll das ok
webgl test gucken wir mal
muss mehr tabs machen mehr tabs tabs
wobei der die tabs wahrscheinlich so spendet wenn ich rausgehe oder
und das funktioniert jetzt
ich würde sagen der cpu limit funktioniert nicht so ganz jetzt habe
ich die limit seite aufgemacht jetzt hat es abgeschossen
genial so nach dem motto alter du hast mich ertappt ich bin über den limit und
nein ich mache jetzt aus toll sehr gut
ok das cpu limit funktioniert nicht ok ram limit ram limit das können wir
einfach überprüfen was sind seite die schön viel ram brauche
facebook facebook brauche massig ram facebook ja gut da muss mal eingeloggt
sein youtube youtube ist auch so eine seite die
mittlerweile riesengroß ist ihr müsst euch mal gucken was youtube mittlerweile
number of fishes max ah ja genau aber das ist eher cpu als ram intensiv würde ich
sagen das ist das fühlt sich auch ziemlich kaputt an schon
am ram ram macht sich number of fishes ok wir machen wir machen jetzt einfach
youtube auf ein paar mal das reicht in der regel schon dass man am ram limit ist
also an dem an diesem an diesem ding da was da eingestellt haben
falscher falscher knopf was mich ein bisschen nervt ist dass man mal gucken ob
ich das glaube wo sind die operas ok jetzt müssen wir hier quick quick
muffs muss man jetzt machen quick muffs wie viel das wirklich ist aber ich hab
irgendwie das gefühl dass dieses limit hier nur zum teil funktioniert weil wir
auch eingestellt haben hart limit
alles denn die knöpfe sind vermutlich sind zu ähnlich das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube ich ach so ja gut der logisch der entleht die tabs einfach ja ok das
ist das ist echt ziemlich also weiß ich ob die funktion so wahnsinnig ist ja
genau denn der entleht die tabs einfach im prinzip genau das was ich gesagt
habe am anfang also ich sehe absolut keinen keinen verwendungszweck zur zeit
also was da browser hat was andere nicht haben was man warum man das verwenden
sollte
ich meine klar wenn ich alle tabs entlade brauche ich wenig ram logisch aber
ich meine auf der anderen seite was soll er auch sonst machen auf der anderen seite das
wollte ich gerade sagen das kann man mit plugins einstellen nein nein uninstall nicht
reinstall ich klicke auch immer auf uninstall wenn ich eigentlich reinstallen will
what is your main reason for uninstalling opera
alles fein ich bin nicht überzeugt
oh ja ach vpn stimmt vpn aber für das ok wir müssen den scheiß noch mal
installieren
mega lull
wo sind meine downloads da
wir müssen es noch mal installieren ja das vpn nicht getestet wurde pc
schon zusammengestellt ein wir wurden ein wenig sei tracked mit dem neuen opera
gaming browser
krasse animation
hi hast du vielleicht einen tipp wenn man das erste mal einen pc zu
zusammenbaut das ist nicht verkehrt wenn einer dabei ist dass er schon mal
gemacht hat das auf jeden auf jeden fall nicht schlecht auf der anderen seite
solange ich gerade mit gewalt irgendwelche sachen irgendwo reindrückst
wo sie nicht reinpassen kann man da gar nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen ich
würde langsam machen ich würde mir einfach zeit nehmen das glaube ich der
beste beste tipp der man geben kann ok also wie macht man vpn an
es war scheinbar nicht dark 7 das schon mal gut ok wie macht man vpn an
tangents history control dass das jui ist schon ein bisschen fail irgendwie
der kennst du gar nix
das grüne schloss das ist das ist ssl zertifikat gedürfnis
laut wie macht man vpn an
whatsapp ok
incognito modus aha ja moment falscher browser incognito modus
man kann ja auch easy setup kann man auch umstellen kann man das auch umstellen
of your pro pro setup die marsch auf den incognito depp auf die private
window ah hier ist vpn ha select location on schön nach china verbinden
europe asia amerikas amerikas wollen wir uns verbinden amerikas ok ja wir können
auch überprüfen ob das auch wirklich ob das auch wirklich funktioniert
moment wo war das jetzt noch mal da überprüfen mal ob das ein richtiges vpn
ist vpn on location amerikas und dann gehen wir mal auf irgendwie so was ist
meine ip oder so also steht da jetzt unity media steht da jetzt unity media
dann ist es fail steht da jetzt steht da jetzt steht da jetzt hier das da dann
ist gut
moment ich bin im falschen
hey funktioniert ip liegt o mfg das rechtsklickmenü ist auch übelst
kaputt könnte es an meiner vm liegen
ja unity media sind auch kacke allerdings unity media haben sich in
letzter zeit tatsächlich mühe gegeben mich wieder ein bisschen von sich zu
überzeugen und vor allem hat sie telekom geschafft einen noch beschisseneren
eindruck zu hinterlassen bei mir nämlich das am wochenende mein dsl anschluss
sich alle paar könnt ihr euch ja noch im stream dran erinnern alle halbe stunde
abgekackt ist max bist du erkältet ich bin sowas von monka sick aber ich habe
keinen bock die ganze zeit im bett zu liegen ok vpn funktioniert vpn ist ein
ganz leises feature davon allerdings kann man solche vpn wahrscheinlich auch in
jedem x beliebigen anderen browser installieren
ansonsten gibt es auch vpn software mit dem man sich auf irgendwelche china vpn
oder so connecten kann wenn man mal wenn man mal irgendwie china mmo spielen
will oder irgendwo was downloaden will gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten ist
ganz nett integriert ja vpn ist das einzige was ich bisher gesehen habe an
dem browser der ganz nice ist allerdings kann es der normale opera auch der
firefox kann ziemlich sicher mit einem erdhorn auch oder vielleicht sogar
mittlerweile out of the box und kaum garantiert auch
das ist kaum mehr ok haben wir uns angeguckt mal wieder aus
gut jetzt können wir uns der eigentlichen sache widmen wofür ich den
stream eigentlich gemacht habe und zwar ich habe mir überlegt ob ich mir nicht
also nachdem wir uns ja das letzte mal zusammen angeguckt haben die neuen
reisen cpus und eigentlich alles samt inklusiv also der stream inklusive mir
also so so huge huge massen an leuten nämlich so 120 oder so immerhin der
meinung waren dass reisen 3 schon übelst nice ist habe ich mir gedacht ich könnte
meinen zweiten pc durch den reisen pc austauschen nicht unbedingt weil das
sein muss sondern eher weil es geht
so wo ist mein pp ab wort auch so viele questions aus euch da komme ich gar nicht
hinterher ist es nicht reisen 2 reisen 3 3 es ist reisen 3
ok ja ok leute ihr habt recht ja aber die heißen amd sagt selbst es ist heißt
reisen 3 was soll ich da machen also ok ja dann dann muss man es ganz korrekt
sagen die architektur ist sen 2 aber die cpu generation nennt sich reisen 3
erst mal gucken ob ich irgendwelche fragen übersehen ab
mcpro leif update reparatur ist doch vom letzten mal noch
das hatten wir doch alles das letzte mal schon
beantwortet
einer knerbe er nervt nicht kann oder dass ich hier nicht hinterher kommen mit
nachrichten wegklicken
haben wir uns angeguckt ja salami prinz verwendest du den als du auch da bist
einfach aufgefallen dass sie sowas haben
gaming router genau
ich kann ich gesehen ich glaube das letzte was mir jetzt irgendwie bei der
erkältung helfen würde ist gfuel zu trinken oder oder was ich letztens
gesehen habe ist wenn wenn es wenn wenn der energie trink nicht mehr reicht
noch mal benutzen den browser selbst oder hast du einfach gesehen dass es
gibt wenn einem der energie trink nicht mehr reicht kann man sich jetzt energie
pillen holen
dann guckt man dann so wahrscheinlich ich weiß nicht ob er so das beste
beispiel dafür ist für das zeug
brian buster
ich weiß dass hilft bestimmt was
je nachdem was da drin ist
das ist allerdings nichts was man auf dauer einschmeißt ja
das ist so was wenn der wenn die irgendwie aufgewacht bist und muss jetzt
schnell wach werden oder so
und weiß du musst die nächsten zwei stunden nicht mal irgendwie
konzentrieren
vielleicht ist das dann was also ich denke schon dass es
dass es nicht rein placebo ist dass es schon sache drin hat die die wirken
ob man das jetzt wirklich braucht
es einmal dahingestellt und das was der wambo schreibt könnte ich mir auch
schon vorstellen weil
er schreibt hier demnächst gibt es noch energie trink zum spritzen
ich würde sich wundern
wenn es
gaming booster zeugs der blick tatsächlich auch intravenös geben
weil man kann sich mittlerweile schon rf aldi spritzen kaufen
kein witz jetzt
das putzen
was ist als pilotnet das das programmaschine bastel hat mit dem chat
ja das ist als pilotnet
also es gibt wirklich es es gibt wirklich
es gibt wirklich rf aldi spritzen
also das ist keine spritze mit dem rf aldi chip
dann wobei doch das ist wortwörtlich eine spritze mit dem rf aldi chip
das ist allerdings nicht dass man die spritze scannt
den rf aldi chip
den kann man sich dann unter die hauen spritzen damit dann seine tür aufmachen
und sowas
wobei ich mal denke ok man kann man kann es also ihr wisst ich treibs mit
heimautomatisierung
schon relativ weit
aber ich finde man kann es auch mit heimautomatisierung und sachen
übertreiben
und dazu gehört für mich sich ein rf aldi chip unter die hauen zu spritzen
vor allem selbst daheim
ich mein und dann noch irgendein china chip oder so
wer weiß was ich dann für komische was ich dann für bakterien gespürt
hast du das overwatch lego gesehen
ach cool
auf der anderen seite was soll man damit machen das ist genauso ein bisschen wie
das minecraft lego was wo ich auch nicht genau wusste was man damit machen soll
aber lego hat irgendwie
den hang da zu sich sich an sich gute lizenzen irgendwie immer zu sichern
allerdings sind wohl das was lego so in letzter zeit macht und und was was lego
verkauft und sowohl auch nicht mehr so das
gelbe vom ei
wobei also den lego hanzo finde ich geil
hanzo
ronzo
also lego hanzo ist cool
was wird hier überdrehen wir gucken uns lego auf auf watch
und eigentlich wollten wir
eigentlich wollten wir uns einen ryzen pc zusammen stellen
also was
hahaha guck mal
genji hat sogar einen healing in der hand
das ist ja lustig
das ist cool
also der der hanzo gefällt mir am besten da rein hat es nicht so was
naja diva sieht halt
so aus wie der ausschaut
der genji gefällt mir tracer gefällt mir nicht
mccree sieht cool aus
der reaper sieht
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie
wie die darth raider figur mit einem hoodie auf
oder solcher sieht zumindest die waffe sieht auch nicht so gut aber der hanzo gefällt mir am besten
eigentlich
das ist eigentlich ganz cool ich wüsste nicht was ich damit machen soll aber
finde ich eine coole idee
ja das ist mir vorhin auch aufgefallen dass dieses photoshop die viewer zahlen
übelst fail waren
das hatten wir schon ich habe keine ahnung unter windows
gibst du bekommst geld von operas plays
90k
link ist der html rennera
das kann sein
so genau kenne ich da den unterschied was wie welche teile vom chrome heißen auch nicht
ich weiß nur
das
mozilla ihre css
engine und ihre
ich glaube auch in html rennera
vor ein paar versionen ausgezauscht hat zu was was komplett in rust programmiert ist
servo hieß das genau
1 vs 1 auf rust genau
ich glaube servo ist das schon mehr oder weniger komplett also wahrscheinlich
nicht komplett alles was in servo drin ist
allerdings die teile diese ersetzt haben sind wohl komplett ersetzt
browser benchmarks hätte ich gar nichts hätte ich gar nicht machen müssen
großartig wir haben uns hier noch im gl benchmark angeguckt
und das war in der vm das war eh nicht so richtig aussage kräftig
ram limit ja gut
macht tabs kaputt
krumm ja wir wissen mittlerweile dass es ein krumm ist
auf was bezog sich das
ja mach ja gaming browser
bei uns das da wo ich arbeite
die haben es noch nicht mal geschafft
dass auf dem windows 10 rechner mittlerweile edge drauf ist na
default browser ist immer noch hinter den explorer 11
und das tolle ist
die haben mittlerweile
wartet mal kurz
und der witz ist wo war ich gerade genau dass die
dass wir auf der aber immer noch internet explorer 11 haben
das mit edge noch nicht auf die reihe gekriegt haben
aber das witzig ist dass wir
ich krieg halt komische messages auf dem handy
ja leute ich glaube ihr merkt ich bin heute nicht so ganz auf der höhe ich vergess
laufen irgendwelche sachen
es ist einfach so wenn man wenn man erkältet ist dann kann man nicht so nicht
so denken zu den es ist das genau stimmt was ich sagen wollte
das lustige ist dass wir mittlerweile halt auf der arbeit an software haben die
überhaupt nicht mehr richtig auf dem internet explorer läuft
was übelster fail ist na
die fortbrowser internet explorer und dann hast du irgendwie sowas wie
wie zum beispiel irgendwie confluence oder so
was ja mittlerweile die meisten oder ganz viele alti leden verwenden
so als als wiki ersatz wobei ich confluence maßlos
aber auch veringeniert finde irgendwie
am und es läuft halt nicht richtig im internet explorer
und dann müssen sich jeden tag damit rumschlagen dass die leute halt
rumkotzen weil sie im internet explorer nicht läuft
wo ich euch ja viel
wie wäre es wenn ihr einfach was ordentliches installiert irgendwie so ein
den firefox oder chrome oder sonst was
und jetzt haben sie sich was ganz tolles neues ausgedacht wir haben jetzt einen
firmen internen
denn was man ab store
ähm was im prinzip einfach in powershell script ist dahinter
ähm
oder ich vermute ich war
ganze lang quasi im im im firmen ab store kannst du dann auswählen ich möchte
jetzt die firefox ab installieren
und dann wird
der läuft im hintergrund in den powershell script lädt das firefox runter installiert
das
und ähm
startet aber den rechner neu weil weiß man nicht
egal was auch immer
wieso benutzt du eigentlich mal firefox und mal chrome ist das nicht
sau anstrengend sich die ganze zeit umzugewinnen
gar nicht
ich benutze
also ich benutze unter linux
oder generell zum arbeiten verwende ich eigentlich hauptsächlich firefox
und so für für twitch gucken und und youtube gucken und zeug verwende ich
eigentlich immer chromium
und chrome verwende ich für hintergrundgeschichten die ich einfach auf hab
ich kann euch den sinn davon nicht genau erklären
es ist aber einfach so wie ich es gewöhnt bin
ich mich dran gewöhnt hab das heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt dass es für jeden
die ultimative lösung ist
max hast du schon mal day of billions gespielt macht übelst bock und ist auch schwer
ähm ich hab's mir gekauft
auf steam
ich hab sogar installiert
ich hab sogar gestartet
ich hab fünf minuten playtime oder so und hab ich wieder ausgemacht
das lag aber gar nicht am spiel
sondern weil ich dann irgendwas anderes machen musste an dem tag und danach hab
ich nie wieder gestartet
du kannst den sinn nicht erklären weil es keinen gibt
das kann auch sein ja das ist genauso sinnvoll wie dass ich laufend
irgendwelche zeichen markieren und copypaste
erstmal den spam vom knerbeer weg machen
3900x oder
r9 kommt der kommt bald
ja hoffe ich drauf
ich will nämlich mal sehen was quasi bei den
bei den besten cpus am den noch zu bieten hat
wie wohl läuft das ppega bord bezogen wird geserved
das
ist
eine mischung aus vue.js
client und
asp.net
core im backend
allerdings ist das
nicht sonderlich sophisticated das sind
es ist ein controller und und irgendwie eine html seite oder so
was hältst du vom raspberry 4
da haben wir komplett eigenen stream schon zugemacht
also ich finde die upgrades gut
allerdings ist es jetzt nicht so das ding wo man sagen würde hey
wahnsinn must have upgrade wenn man wenn man nicht gerade
mehr usb speed braucht
oder mal netzberg speed
gibt es kein websocket support von der twitch api
keine ahnung
wir machen es aber nicht über die twitch api wir machen es über den twitch irc chat
das ppega bord ist super super simpel das ist im prinzip
ist das eine große schleife mit über den twitch irc hier
heißt sogar schon noch lub das ding
das ist eine große schleife über
über den twitch irc
und dann schreibt das in die datenbank wenn es eine neue nachricht gibt
und
die webseite zeigt einfach nur die nachricht aus der datenbank an das ist
ziemlich simpel ich wollte übrigens auf github pushen fällt mir gerade so ein
was hältst du von opera aus privaten programmierst du ich verwende es nicht
man kann es bestimmt gut verwenden es ist ein chrome drunter
aber ich hab mittlerweile ich hab ein chromium ich hab ein firefox ich hab
theoretisch einen edge drauf ich hab nen chrome
ich hab nen vivaldi
also ich brauche also einen weiteren browser brauche ich wirklich nicht mehr
was auf webassembly porten
so ok da können wir jetzt mal zur eigentlichen sache kommen die ich
eigentlich machen wollte im stream
nämlich
den pc zusammenschauen und gucken was es überhaupt gibt
was programmierst du gerade gar nicht wir wollten eigentlich also die ursprüngliche idee
war
uns den ryzen rechner zusammenzustellen
den ich als streaming pc verwenden kann
ich habe ja schon einen hier
aktuell hab ich den da
als zweiten rechner hier stehen
den verwende ich allerdings noch gar nicht als ich glaube der rechner ist es
ich verwende den aber gar nicht als streaming rechner im sinne dass ich
quasi
dort render und streamer
sondern ich verwende den zweiten rechner aktuell nur als
als vorschau
also sprich ich hab nen browser auf ich hab meinen stream auf
ich hab hier mein web interface für meine für meine emotes und gedöns offen
für meinen text to speech offen
ähm
den chat hab ich auf so das war's also da render ich nix drüber und hab mir gedacht
hey
das könntest du doch eigentlich über einen zweiten rechner machen
dass die quali nämlich noch ein bisschen besser bei niedriger bitrate
weil aktuell mach ich ja mit 1080p 8-pitch fps
und gerendert wird
über die 1080ti
und
grafikkarten
encoding ist einfach qualitativ ne ganze ecke schlechter vor allem halt eben auf
mittleren bitraten
wie cpu encoding
ich fände es nur fair wenn du den rechner in einem zuschauer schenken würdest
auch ist das fair
ist das fair weil ich den rechner bezahlt hab oder was
ich weiß ja nicht was ich mit dem alten rechner mache
ähm genau also in dem in meinem aktuellen in anführung des streaming rechner
ist ist halt ist das aktuell drin
nicht mal ganz original wie damals
also ich hab drinnen eine 2 terabyte ssd
komplett komplett
sinnlos in dem zweiten rechner
die werde ich auch behalten es gibt keinen grund die ssd irgendwie auszutauschen
wir können in dem in dem geiz als bild an der m2 ssd rein machen oder so aber
es ist total
hast du dir ein neues nv eng für rtx angeschaut
das ist genauso gut wie x 264 medium
sicher gibt es auch schon unabhängige tests zu
ein medium reicht
ich würde auch sonst nichts über medium einstellen
ja leute vielleicht wird es dann endlich mal zeit für eine 2080 ti
moment das ist
falsche manche sucht
und das kriegen und das
ok das kann nur eine rtx oder was
das ist gar nicht so schlecht
youtube man die regel
no happy meal for you weißt du wie viel ich kanns jetzt ich kanns euch nicht
zeigen das steht antriffe alles drauf weißt du wie viel youtube mann ich
letzten monat gemacht habe ich sage es dir
es kommt hier
wie viel ich gucke jetzt extra in den e-mails nach
wie viel youtube mann ich gemacht habe
es ist auf jeden fall ein
absolut huge amount youtube mann gewesen ist so viel kann ich das jetzt schon mal
vorwegnehmen
wahnsinnig viel
wo ist denn hier
new message vom aliexpress nein das ist nichts was mit youtube zu tun hat
tube 1 neue gutschrift
öffnen pdf
14 euro 27 youtube money
hab ich den letzten monat verdient
also massive
was lustigerweise immer noch ganz gut funktioniert ist amazon ref links
amazon ref links ist eh das beste was man machen kann
amazon ref links ist wirklich nice
wenn man da mal seine ref links ordentlich
gestreut hat
man kriegt ja dann irgendwie also normalerweise kriegst du ja nur innerhalb
der nächsten 48 stunden wenn einer zuletzt über den ref link auf amazon
gegangen ist was
aber wenn man seine ref links ordentlich gestreut hat verdient man damit eigentlich
immer ganz gut
genau als richtig das wollte ich grad sagen
die leute haben sich die sachen halt gebuchtmarkt
oder haben sie ne history oder sowas
das ist halt das ist halt wirklich nice
und das schöne an amazon ref links ist halt dass es komplett
es ist halt es ist nicht negativ für die leute drüber kaufen ja
also bezahlt es exakt das gleich über ref links oder nicht ref links
das es gibt eigentlich wenn man es mal genau nimmt
wenn man
es sei denn man sagt ey ich gönn
gönn keinem irgendwie was
es ist eigentlich
am sinnvollsten nur über ref links zu kaufen dann kann man ja die ref links raussuchen
von den leuten wo man
das halt supporten will
aber amazon ref links bringt tatsächlich was
die sind immer noch dreistellig im monat
durch die bank weg dreistellig
aber an weihnachten an weihnachten auch ein bisschen mehr allerdings
habe ich jetzt die letzten jahre keine vierstelligen
ref links sachen mehr gehabt aber ich mach ja auch kaum was
aber du siehst dann doch was derjenige kauft das sieht man nicht personalisiert
ähm
ich grabe immer über max ref links vor dem kaufen ref macht den ref rauss
dazu gar nicht das ist halt
gaunt hier
wie die robbe
du siehst nicht direkt was die leute kaufen du siehst was gekauft wurde
du hast aber keine möglichkeit irgendwie festzustellen wer was gekauft hat
du siehst einfach nur
äh 20 ähm
kisten nudeln oder so keine ahnung
aber du siehst nicht wer
und du siehst auch nicht die orders einzeln also du siehst bloß insgesamt
und du siehst auch nicht wieviel sondern du siehst nur
ähm keine ahnung ich habe jetzt von keine ahnung sonnenbrillen habe ich
irgendwie 5,70 euro
affiliate gekriegt
das war das komische was man auch weiß gar nicht
ich bin auch nicht so gut im im im nachdenken
zu zu monka sick
ok also wie gesagt zurück zurück zurück zum eigentlichen thema
kaufst du auch über den ref link ähm bringt nix weil
amazon ist schon nicht nicht blöde
du kannst nicht über deinen eigenen reflink kaufen
funktioniert nicht
es sei denn, nee zweiter account bringt auch nix es sei denn es sei denn
du machst einen zweiten account
mit einem anderen mit einer anderen ähm
mit einem anderen name und eine andere lieferanschrift
aber einen anderen streamer könnte man trotzdem oder schon klar
aber das bringt nix
also amazon reflinks
lohnen sich nur in der menge
so für meine für meine selbst weil ich bestell ja relativ viel insgesamt aber
selbst für meine sagen wir mal irgendwie 30 bestellungen oder so
ist nicht die regel aber kann schon mal sein
ist es jetzt auch nicht so die menge
egal ist genau zurück hier zu der zum zum eigentlichen rechner konfigurieren
ähm
also das ist das was aktuell drin ist zwei terabyte ssd
im zweiten rechner die werde ich auch behalten
ähm
die grafikkarte ist schon lange raus
da ist aktuell eine 980ti drinne
ähm
kühler und cpu das ist eine 4k cpu die ist sogar noch ziemlich gut
weil sich die letzten jahre cpu technisch gar nicht so viel getan hat
allerdings cpu encoding
ist da auch nicht viel mehr drinne wie 1080p mit mit irgendwie 860 fps wenn du
das auf dem ordentlichen quality setting machst
ram ist noch der gleiche drin das netzteil ist auch noch das gleiche mainboard noch das gleiche und
gehäuse im prinzip auch noch das gleiche also eigentlich vollkommen
ausreichend als streaming pc
aber ich habe mir gedacht warum bauen wir nicht einen ryzen rechner zusammen
was ich natürlich interessant finde
weil es jetzt ja gerade jemand im stream geschrieben hat
dass die neuen rtx gpus
ähnlich gute quality haben
wie cpu encoding
das heißt vielleicht
wäre es auch viel sinnvoller
anstatt dass ich mir einen zweiten pc hole zum encoden
einfach
2080ti zu holen
und weiterhin einfach auf meinem main pc zu encoden
können wir auch machen
oder ich mach mal wieder ein paar videos und nerv ein video ob ich eine kriege
aber
das würde ja dann noch ein bisschen dauern
wie wäre es mit manjaro und dann kvm pass-through nach windows
das ist nicht sonderlich stabil denke ich mal auf dauer
sobald ich die meisten sachen halt unter windows mache
und
das problem an
gpu pass-through ist
dass du ja die
grafikkarte also du reichst ja die grafikkarte komplett durch was auch heißt
dass du dann einen monitor brauchst
das ist nicht so dass du deine fenster drinne hast
oder dass die anzeigen lassen kannst also es ist im prinzip mehr wie ein zweiter rechner
und ein zweiter rechner für den du natürlich eine extra maus brauchst eine extra
tastatur wenn du das dann mit drauf spielen willst
weil das würde ich nicht machen mit
emuliert über kvm
und dann hast du im prinzip quasi
zwei rechner nur in einem mit dem gleichen aufwand
wo man sich halt fragt wie ist das
ne looking class geht nicht
ich kann jetzt leider nicht mehr genau sagen was das problem war
also looking class ist diese geschichte diese high performance
über ram kopieren von bildern von kvm zu
zu haussystem
das ging aber nicht
für diese zwecke
ich kann ja leider nicht mehr genau sagen warum
ich hatte mir das damals vielleicht geht es auch mittlerweile ich weiß es
aber nicht mehr was es war
ich habe mir das damals angeguckt
und dachte auch erst mal übelst nice
aber das hat einen hacken gehabt ich weiß aber leider nicht mehr welchen
aber vielleicht gibt es den auch gar nicht mehr mittlerweile
ich kann ja aber nicht mehr sagen was es gewesen ist
so ganz habe ich noch nicht verstanden wieso du einen zweiten rechner brauchst
ne ich wollte den zweiten rechner verwenden
zum als als wie ich es jetzt auch schon mache
als vorschau und als steuerung für irgendwie zum beispiel emotes und sonst was
für die für die anzeige vom chat für den vorschau vom stream
plus dass ich mir halt gedacht habe wenn ich eh schon einen rechner nachstehen habe umlaufen
dann kann ich auch mein encoding auf dem zweiten rechner machen
und dann halt mit besserer quali stream oder halt mit besserer qualität bei
niedriger bitrate stream
allerdings
wenn wirklich das
encoding auf den neuen nvidia karten so gut ist wie
x 264 h 26
encoding auf der cpu früher
auf medium setting und mehr würde ich eh nicht machen
dann ist die frage ob sich das tatsächlich lohnt
was wir allerdings mal machen können ist das wollte ich mir nämlich schon
anschauen
quasi eher luxo
wobei also
ich das ist eine sache das würde ich würde ich empfehlen also wenn man wenn
man strengt ich würde auf jeden fall gucken dass ich zumindest mal einen zweiten monitor
anschließe
ähm
oder halt einen alten rechner so eine vorschau und so
und einen einen zweiten rechner da nichts mit dem anderen zu tun hat ist gut
wenn man eben was nachgucken will und nicht oft sein passport eintippen will am
stream und sowas
also einen zweiten rechner daneben stehen zu haben ist schon auf jeden fall
auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt
gibt doch nveng versus
das da
popke popke ist immer ziemlich ziemlich verwaschen gewesen mit den freunden mit
dem alten
die sache ist plus die in youtube videos sieht man das halt schlecht
ich meine das sieht schon auf den ersten blick
deutlich besser aus hier
aber das das das ist schwierig zu sehen ich meine es ist ungefähr die gleiche
szene
aber es ist nicht es ist nicht das gleiche bild das aber schon mal schwierig
zu vergleichen es sieht
es sieht links schon
deutlich deutlich besser aus
als rechts
wer spielt das spiel überhaupt keine ahnung aber es ist das spiel ist für
solche in koning test ziemlich gut
nveng versus nveng
ist auch mehr oder weniger
ich kann danach noch mal gucken was es noch gibt
aber hier erkennt man es eigentlich ganz gut also das sieht wirklich besser aus
als auf der anderen seite keine frage
ja hier erkennt man es jetzt wieder nicht richtig
x-up
versus new nveng
ok und welches davon ist jetzt das
deiner deiner ansicht nach ordentliche video
das zweite
das da
ok schauen wir mal
ein stream key liegt
vor allem streaming performance sehr gut
die performance ist jetzt auch ziemlich heiß ich brauche ein bisschen
so richtig gut sieht man das eigentlich nur in der bewegung
einfach ob es an kanten pixelt und sowas
oder vor allem auch bei bilderübergängen ob es zwischendurch irgendwie pixelt
ich meine ok was man was man hier schon auf jeden fall erkennt ist
das wenn du dir hier so die details anguckst dass das eine ganze ecke
gar nicht wirklich
ach das ist cpu wollte ich gerade sagen
das ist altes nveng neues nveng
ich muss ehrlich sagen im standbild sehe ich da überhaupt keinen unterschied
ich erkenne absolut kein unterschied
was doch ein reisen ja das ist
habe ich eigentlich vor
aber vielleicht wird es auch eine neue grafik
also da hat es vielleicht auch mal in aktion irgendwo
wir brauchen wir brauchen was wir brauchen was animiertes
fps ist wurscht
fps haben wir genug
die ticken weniger pixelig aus aber wenn das nicht exakt das gleiche ist
ich fand das pubge video eigentlich am besten
da hat man es also ich finde wenn also wenn das wenn das wirklich ist man
erkennt den unterschied schon
aber es ist jetzt nicht so ultra
gut zu erkennen aber das ist auch immer problematisch das in youtube videos zu
erkennen
ich gebe es ein paar bilder
ich gebe es ein paar bildchen dazu mal irgendwas in 4k oder so
ja super in
1024 erkennt man es nicht richtig
du steams doch nur sowieso keine games werden das liegt daran dass keine
gescheiten games aktuell gibt
okay
so
Also ganz überzeugt bin ich davor noch nicht
Ach so das ist die obs version wie das kann aha
Gut
Da muss ich mal gucken oder falls jemand wirklich gute vergleich screenshots hat oder vielleicht auch
Ähm gute vergleich videos in ordentlicher bitrate mit mit ordentlicher ordentlicher auflösung das wäre wirklich nicht verkehrt
Weil das wäre tatsächlich ein pluspunkt wo ich mir überlegen könnte nicht vielleicht doch in 2080
Die zu nehmen da ist jemand krank ja
Ja das das stimmt schon also der eine du weißt schon also im stream ihr erkennt es gar nicht und ich erkenne es ich erkenne es über youtube auch kaum
Den unterschied
Aber das was wir auf jeden fall machen können was mich nämlich wirklich mal interessiert wird ist was es für mainboards für ryzen 3 gibt oder im prinzip ist ja glaube ich der sockel noch mehr oder weniger das gleiche
Es gibt auch in sessio 27 es gibt auch
Es gibt auch call of duty 13 oder so jetzt was ist das jetzt eigentlich
Was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich warte mal das mal überlegen das neue modern warfare ist ok warte mal gott 4 gott 5
Black ops ok warte mal mit bis gott 5 ist die sache klar black ops ist 6
Mw2 ist 7
Äh ghost ist 8 ne ne black ops 2 ist 8 ghost ist 9 ach du scheiße ich hab keine ahnung
Wicky bear
Black ops 3 ist 8 ghost ist 9 ach du scheiße ich hab keine ahnung
ne black ops kann nicht 5 sein Call of Duty 5 hieß 5
Da, das da, ne. Moment. Das da, World of War ist 5. Ok, also 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16. Alter, 16. 16, ernsthaft, ey. Und gespielt richtig hab ich nicht mehr
seit, seit da so. Krass. Dings hier, Playgrounds 4 fand ich am Anfang gar nicht so schlecht.
Mein Streamchat Ding hat sich aufgehängt. Echt jetzt? Ist RIP? Mein Streamchat RIP?
Ne, ist es nicht. Streamchat funktioniert noch. Oder meinst du, meinst du, meinst du,
meinst du, meinst du das da? Das muss ich refreschen. Achso. Playgrounds 4 war so lange
geil bis die Noobs LMG mit Thermal hatten. So lange hab ich das geil gespielt. Ok, aber
was mich wirklich mal interessieren würde ist, was es für Mainboards Horizon gibt.
Also ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, wenn ich mir, und wie gesagt, das ist auch nicht ganz
klar. Ich muss mir das erstmal mit der RTX angucken. Also ich hab mir überlegt, wenn
ich mir einen Ryzen Streaming PC hole, dann wollte ich mal schauen, ob es Mainboards gibt,
die ne Onboard 10G Karte haben. Vielleicht gibt's sowas. Das ist zumindest nice. Ansonsten
brauche ich mindestens drei PCI Express Slots, aber das haben wahrscheinlich die meisten.
Ich brauche einen für die Capture Karte, ich brauche einen für die Grafikkarte, ich brauche
einen für die 10G, ne Zwergkarte. Also gucken wir mal, was ist denn der richtige Sockel
überhaupt? Der da, ne? AM4. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen TR4 und AM4? Ach, der Threat Ripper
ist das TR4, ne? Das ist für den fetten. Okay, und X570 ist das Richtige, das hab ich
heute schon mal gesehen. Also, X570. Okay, und dann wollten wir mal gucken, ob es vielleicht
wirklich was mit 10G? Wo kann man hier einstellen, was für Netzwerkkarte? Hier. Ah, okay, es
gibt ganze zwei Boards mit 10G. Wahrscheinlich wie der SROC. Ne. Amos Eye Prestige X570 Creation
oder Gigabyte Aorus Xtreme. Nochmal auf Topic. Wegen DNS glaubst du ein Raspberry Pi 3 hätte
die Performance, um darauf einen DNS Server für 10-15 Geräte laufen zu lassen? Locker.
Locker, DNS braucht nichts. Das kannst du auf einem für 10 Geräte DNS kannst du auf
einem SRO laufen lassen und der langweilt sich mit 1% Cebu auslassen. Gut, SRO über
WLAN ist vielleicht nicht so tolle, aber DNS braucht nichts. Moment. Warte mal, was kostet
das Mainboard? Die sind auch nicht mal ganz dicht, oder? 776 Euro, 462 Euro, was sind
das für Mainboards? Sind die vergoldet oder so? Hat der nigerianische Prinz irgendwie
seine Millionen? Warum ist das so teuer? Ich muss mal gucken, warum das so teuer ist.
Warum ist dieses Mainboard so teuer? Moment, war das das teure? Ne, das ist das das teure.
Warum ist das so teuer? Moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal ergründen. 400 Euro, guter Mittelklasse.
Was ist das für ein Preis? Jenseits, die sind immer ganz dicht. Wobei, über MSI darf
ich flamen. Die kriegen das eh nicht mehr mit, weil MSI hat mich schon seit Jahren
auf Twitter geploggt. Und ich weiß bis heute nicht genau warum. Wahrscheinlich, ich glaube,
weil ich mich über RGB-Beleuchtung von ihren Mainboards mal lustig gemacht hab, vor, keine
Ahnung, sieben Jahren oder so. Dann haben sie gesagt, ne Max, also, mit dir haben wir
nichts mal zu tun haben, wenn du dich über RGB-Beleuchtung lustig machst. Ok, was hat
das Ding jetzt, dass es 800 Euro Wert macht? AMD X570 Aero-Smell-Mod, Direct, 16 Faces,
Infineon Digital 4M. Ich weiß ja nicht mehr, was das überhaupt bedeuten soll. 16 Faces
klingt nach Stromversorgung für CPU. Ich weiß aber noch nicht, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht, was dieser Satz hier, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Infineon Digital VRM. Was ist
VRM? Der Verkehrsverbot Rhein-Mosel. Ja, der wird es bestimmt sein. What is VRM? Ah,
Voltage Regulator. Ah, ja. Dann ergibt das auch Sinn. Da war ich doch mit Stromversorgung
für die CPU gar nicht so weit weg. Österreichische Crossfads, ja, super. Die waren bestimmt die
700 Euro. Ich weiß nicht mehr, ist es bestimmt wert. Ok, Fins Array Heatsink. Wo immer. Nano-Carbon-Base
Blades. Alter. Das brauch ich bei meinem Mainboard schon immer mal gebraucht. Eine Carbon-Platte.
Hast du da ein schön leichtes Mainboard? Ein schön stabiles, leichtes Mainboard? Aber
hast dein Fractal-Design sonst was Gehäuse mit 12 Kilo? Ok, Triple PCI 4.0 M2 hat mein
aktuelles Mainboard auch und das hat keine 800 Euro gekostet. Ok, sorry, nein, stimmt
nicht. Mein aktuelles Mainboard hat keine Triple PCI Express 4.0 M2. Allerdings ist
es fragwürdig, ob der Unterschied überhaupt messbar ist mit aktuellen M2 NVMe SSDs, die
man so kaufen kann. So, dann hat man noch irgendwelche Thermal Guards, die was auch immer machen,
gucken, dass die Dinger nicht so warm werden. Ich wusste gar nicht, ich hab noch nie von
dem Fall gehört, dass SSDs überhitzen. Do I have to worry about overheating on SSDs?
Yes you should. Oh, oh, MonkaS. Tatsächlich. Ich hab noch nie irgendwo gelesen bis jetzt,
dass jemand Probleme hatte, weil seine SSD überhitzt ist. New World Order 1988. Hab
100k Down, Top-Lan-Kabel, alle Ports am Router offen, das würde ich nicht machen, und fliege
trotzdem wegen Netzwerkfehler aus jedem Spiel. Wieso? Bist du bei Unity Media? Oder bist
du bei einem Kabelanbieter? Telekom? Hast du mal mit WLAN probiert? Nur mal um Fehler
auszuschließen? WLAN an Router dran? Ach ja, und alle Ports würde ich auch nicht aufmachen.
Also was verstehst du unter alle Ports aufmachen? Hast du für jede 65.535 Ports eine Portweiterleitung
eingetragen oder was? Das stelle ich mir ziemlich zeitintensiv vor. Ach Moment, stimmt ja gar
nicht, TCP und UDP, also 70.000 Ports. Ich weiß, dass man Rangers eintragen kann, das
war jetzt so eine Frage, ja. Also das würde ich nicht machen. Normalerweise brauchst du
überhaupt nichts mehr weiterleiten, es sei denn, und das ist eigentlich schon eine Weile
so, es sei denn du willst irgendwelche Lobbies hosten oder so. Wenn du einfach nur mitspielen
willst, musst du in der Regel gar nichts weiterleiten. Oder aber du kannst probieren, wie hieß das,
wie gesagt, ich habe es heute mit nachdenken nicht so, Erkältung ist wirklich so Brainblock,
wie heißt das Ding? Das dynamische Portweiter, UPnP, nicht Hamachi, UPnP, kannst du einschalten.
Also es ist sehr schwierig, das jetzt Remote zu diagnostizieren, New World Order 108. Ich
würde mir erstmal angucken, was das für ein Netzwerkfehler ist. Ja, poste doch mal, gibt
es denn eine Fehlernummer oder so, mit was du rausfliegst? Können wir mal gucken. Ansonsten
würde ich mich mit ein paar WLAN verbinden, gar nicht übers Kabel gehen, sicher ist sicher,
mal ausstellen, mal auch ein paar Außensachen ausschließen. Ansonsten würde ich auch mal
die Telekom fragen, ob die nicht komische Dinge treiben. Auch noch interessant zu gucken,
ob du dich zum PSN über IPv6 oder IPv4 verbindest, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das mittlerweile
über IPv6 überhaupt geht, nur mal so, können wir mal schauen. Naja gut, auf Topic, wenn
ich auf einem ESXi System eine VM erstelle und per PCI pass through eine Grafikkarte
zuweise, kann ich dann die Videoausgabe der Grafikkarte nutzen, um die VM zu scheinen.
Moment, was? Das ist gerade zu viel für mein Hirn heute. Wenn ich auf einem ESXi System
eine VM erstelle und per PCI pass through eine Grafikkarte zuweise, kann ich dann die
Videoausgabe der Grafikkarte... Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich bin heute zu brain lag. Meinst
du, ob du die VM benutzen kannst, um dein ESXi über das Webinterface zu steuern? Magst
Take Support, FPS. Ja, was machen wir? Ich meine, besser als der Fake in der Microsoft
Support. Will wissen, ob er einen extra Monitor anschließen kann. Klar kannst du das machen.
Du musst sogar einen extra Monitor anschließen. Du musst sogar einen extra Monitor anschließen,
wenn du GPU pass through machst. Old City Switch Lite, ne sehe ich keinen Vorteil drinne
für mich. Ich spiele eh kaum Switch und eigentlich auch kaum Mobil. Na klar musst du, wenn du
GPU pass through machst und was sehen willst von der Grafikkarte, also von der Grafikausgabe
der Grafikkarte, dann musst du den Monitor anschließen. Das ist ja gerade der Sinn von
pass through. Du kannst zum Beispiel den H264 Encoder verwenden und die Grafikausgabe machen
über ESXi oder so. Das geht. Aber wenn du GPU pass through machst, dann ist ja quasi
die GPU direkt an der VM dran. Da ist ja nichts mehr dazwischen, was hier irgendwie die Sache
abgreifen könnte. Ich mein klar, da gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche Zusatzdinger, irgendwelche
Remote Desktop Sachen und so. Aber wenn du die durchgereichte Grafikkarte dementsprechend
auch performant nutzen willst, dass du da auch irgendwelche 3D Sachen drüber ausgibst,
dann musst du den eigenen Monitor anschließen, andersher geht das nicht. Welche Ryzen CPU
holst du denn? Das ist noch gar nicht so genau raus. Das weiß ich noch nicht. Ich will erst
mal gucken, was für ein Mainboard. Und wir waren eigentlich gerade dabei zu gucken, warum
dieses Mainboard so unglaublich teuer ist. Beat Pro, du musst dir ganz einfach vorstellen,
wo das Bildsignal langläuft. Läuft es in irgendeiner Form durch deine Host-GPU durch,
weil es irgendwie so ein Zusatzding ist, was nur für irgendwelche Sachen eingeschaltet
wird, keine Ahnung. So wie früher, falls du noch jemand so die Voodoo 2 Dinger kennt.
Das war eine reine 3D-Karte. Das heißt, du hast auf jeden Fall noch eine normale Grafikkarte
gebraucht, wo das dann durchgeschleift wurde. Die muss man auch mit so einem Kabel verbinden.
Dann geht es durch deine Host-GPU durch und wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie durch dein
Host-System und gut ist. Aber bei einem GPU Pass-Through, wenn du da in irgendeine 3D-Anwendung
startest auf dieser durchgereichten Grafikkarte, das Bildsignal kommt ja aus dem HDMI-Anschluss
von einer Grafikkarte raus. Wie soll das in dein Host-System reinkommen? Du hast ja
die Grafikkarte direkt durchgereicht. Da kriegt dein Host dir überhaupt nichts von
mit. Ich meine, du kannst dann im Host wieder eine Capture-Card anschließen und es wieder
zu Capture'n, wobei es dann sie ein bisschen in Frage stellt, warum man, ne. Aber es wird
natürlich gehen. Ja, und diese Geschichte mit Looking Glass, das habe ich mir auch schon
vor einer Weile angeguckt. Das ist für KVM irgendein High-Performance-Wilddaten-Kopier-Ding.
Ich weiß aber nicht mal, was der Haken da dran war. Es hat auf jeden Fall irgendeinen
Haken, warum ich gesagt habe, äh, ich weiß nicht. Wir müssten das mal ausprobieren.
Ich hab ja hier einen Rechner dann stehen. Also ich hab sogar mehrere Rechner stehen,
mit denen wir das ausprobieren könnten. Ich hab die alte Xeon-Kiste da, sollte ich mir
jetzt eine neue Ryzen holen. Und ich hab meinen alten, oder meinen alten, ey, was ein Schwachsinn
eigentlich, meine 4HE-Server-Kiste hier noch stehen. Die kann auch PCIe Express Pass-Through
ausprobieren. Das könnten wir mal ausprobieren Onstream. Was sagt ihr dazu? Das probieren
wir mal aus. PCIe Express Pass-Through unter Linux, ähm, mal ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Im Strebensohr. Könnte man machen. Probieren wir mal aus. Okay, ähm, also warum ist diese
scheiß Mainboard so teuer? Ähm, Triple PCIe, das hatten wir schon. Neun SSDs gehen wahrscheinlich,
also wenn ihr SSDs hast, die das unterstützen, gehen wahrscheinlich massive ab. Ähm, es
ist die Frage, ob man das braucht. Ich meine aktuelle NVMe-SSDs haben irgendwie 3000 MB
die Sekunde und die neuen haben dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, wahrscheinlich doppelte oder
so. Ähm, ob man das, also man wird das in so einem reinen sequentiellen Benchmark wahrscheinlich
merken, aber ob man das wirklich messen kann, wenn man halbwegs realistische Sachen macht,
die nicht einfach nur am Stück lesen, am Stück schreiben, wage ich mal zu bezweifeln, dass
irgendwie so der große, große Verkaufsargument ist. Ähm, Green Earth, kann schon sein, ich
muss mir das mal angucken, ich hab mich auch null mit beschäftigt. Okay, was ist ein ESS
Saber, das ist, ah, das ist Soundcard. Intel, WLAN, Wi-Fi, 6, 3, okay, das kann, ähm,
was ist AX nochmal, ist das Multi-Channel-Gedöns gewesen beim WLAN? WLAN-Standards, wer merkt
sich denn sowas? Ja, genau. Da brauchst du aber auch den Pass-In-Access-Point dazu, den
wahrscheinlich kaum jemand hat. Kappa vergessen, ich hab, ich hab's weder so noch so verstanden,
ich hab's gar nicht kapiert, Green Earth, weil ich null Überblick hab, was es da gibt
aktuell. Ähm, okay, die 10, das ist die exakt gleiche 10G-Karte, die ich auch gerade
drinne hab, die kostet übrigens alleine glaube ich 60 Euro oder sowas, ähm, und das Ganze
auch nur, weil's ne, weil's ne Gigabit, weil's ne 10 Gigabit, ähm, Kupferkarte ist, die
sind, ich glaub kostet ein bisschen mehr, 90 Euro oder so, 95 Euro, ähm, und einfach
nur weil's ne Kupferkarte ist, die SFP-Plus-Karten sind viel, viel billiger, also falls, falls
jemand wirklich ernsthaft vorhat, 10G daheim zu verwenden, ich hab ja den Schwachsinn gemacht
vor, vor drei Jahren, eigentlich komplett, over, over-engineert, oversized und bringt
kaum was, aber ich hab's ja vor ein paar Jahren gemacht, ähm, ich kann's nur, ich kann's
an der Stelle nur empfehlen, sofern's möglich ist, macht's über SFP-Plus und Glasfaser
oder wenn die Strecke nicht so lang ist, über SFP-Plus, ähm, Direct-Attached-Kabel,
es ist einfach viel billiger als mit Kupferkabel, sowohl die Hardware, die Switches sind billiger,
ähm, die Netzwerkkarten sind billiger, die Kabel sind ein bisschen teurer, aber ansonsten
hat man eigentlich nur Vorteile, ok, was haben wir ansonsten noch schönes, ok, ah, es hat
zwei Netzwerkkarten, na gut, das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt 800 Euro wert, hat, hat,
mein Mainboard hat übrigens drei Netzwerkkarten, ich hab davon bis heute nur eine verwendet,
äh, RGB, was für ein Ding, haha, ja, haha, der RGB Fan Commander, was ist das denn, kannst
du da, die Lüfter, je nachdem, wie die angeleucht, ach du Scheiße, haha, gut, wenn man's braucht,
ja, ok, gut, ja, wenn man's braucht, meinetwegen, ja, RGB Fusion 2.0 sagt halt einem überhaupt
gar nichts, ach ja, übrigens, ich seh grad, wir haben fast 19 Uhr, ähm, wollen wir uns,
könnt ihr euch entscheiden, wollen wir uns jetzt die Modern Warfare, den Modern Warfare
Stream angucken, so zumindest mal, zumindest mal ein bisschen reingucken, wie das Gameplay
so aussieht, oder sagt ihr, juckt mich nicht die Bohne, äh, ok, ja, ihr wollt, sehr schön,
machen wir das, das wird, ok, dann gucken wir, dann suchen wir jetzt den Stream schon mal
raus, dann gucken wir uns gleich das Board noch weiter an, ähm, 2 vs 2, wo gibt's den
Stream, Xbox Dynasty, äh, Co-Rage, das ist bestimmt so ein Dude mit 2 Millionen Abos,
ich hab noch nie was von ihm gehört, ziemlich akkurat, oder, ach, direkt unter Call of Duty
Twitch, ja, das wär auch irgendwie sinnvoller, äh, oder auch nicht, denn die zeigen heute
zum ersten Mal richtig Modern Warfare 2, äh, Gameplay, sag mal gibt's da, Twitter, wir gucken
einfach was die offiziell geschrieben haben, ja, Twitter nervt nicht, ja, Tune in tomorrow,
Leute, wie wär's, wenn ihr einfach mal nen Stream hinschreibt, so, äh, ist Syndicate
nicht der, nicht der, der Zombie Dude, ist das nicht der Zombie Dude, ich bin da bisschen
outdated was das angeht, ja, der CSGO Scammer, ist das der CSGO Scammer, okay, also, was
für Streams braucht man, äh, TP, Co-Rage, oh, Donation, dankeschön für die Donation,
muss mal gucken, wie viel's da jetzt gab, weil man Tippy Streamer wieder nicht mag,
äh, Donation, der Flo, Bugs Partnerwerber, schon wieder, hast vergessen, ja, ja, mach
ich, mach ich, sag ich jedes Mal, ne, übrigens danke für die ganzen Follows, ich seh jetzt
leider nur gerade Tata Stresemann und Seliger, als es noch mehr gab, leider seh ich's grad
nicht, ähm, wie hieß das nochmal, Twitch Together gab's doch so ne Seite, Multitwitch,
ne, war das Multitwitch, nicht dass es jetzt ne Pornseite ist oder so, konnte man alles
aufmachen, egal, wir machen mal Syndicate auf Twitch, es ist ja gut, was ist denn hier
los, Donations ohne Ende, alle Partnerbewerbungen, ja, ist okay, ich mach's ja, ich mach's ja,
okay, der ist offline, der müsste allerdings in 4 Minuten online kommen, ähm, war Multitwitch,
not secure, ach Multitwitch.live, wirklich, ich dachte ich jetzt debatet werde, ah, der
ist 16.90, ah, Welcome, Add a Channel, okay, nochmal ein Syndicate rein, den brauchen wir,
dann brauchen wir, äh, wie hieß der andere, TP, jetzt is aber gut Leute, ja, PayPal, ja
Ich bin auch die einzigen die von dir gerade richtig Kohle kriegen ist Paypal
Wir machen mal den Chat weg
Pistisch Chat
So, wen haben wir sonst noch gehabt? Syndicate
Die sind die Leute
CourageJD
Ich kenne die alle nicht außer Syndicate
Ja, übelste Noob was das angeht
Äh, Seite?
Vielleicht ein bisschen breiter machen, so
Sieht man nicht viel
Und Legi-Glory-Legium-Kun
Ok
Ich will dass die Chats weg
Was ist das für eine Kackseite?
Was ist das hier?
Chat on oben rechts
Ok, oben rechts ist ausgeblendet
Ahhhh
Ok, geht los
Geht los
Jetzt muss man das auch noch selbst Scalen oder was? Das für eine Seite
Auto, on
Ah, oder auch nicht
Auto, off
Wo ist der Unterschied? On
So Leute, ich äh, ich habe jetzt noch eine Minute Zeit, ich gehe jetzt mal kurz pinkeln
Afk-Klo
Wir gucken uns das übrigens nicht so an, wir machen den Stream dann in Vollscreen, der am interessantesten aussieht
Multistream.am, ok
Passt auf Porn-Seite jetzt
Ne
Warum ist das überhaupt kein offizielles Event? Die kriegen da doch garantiert Kohle für
Also mit Sicherheit kriegen die da Kohle für
Wenn ich mir überlege, was die damals bei diesem komischen EA-Partnerprogramm schon bezahlt haben kriegen und kriegt jemand mit 2 Millionen Twitch-Followern wahrscheinlich nochmal eine ganze Ecke mehr
Ah, ok
Das ist doch viel, das ist die Seite, die ich gesucht habe, die habe ich letztens bei Seagull im Stream gesehen
Kann man Chat hier ausblenden? Ja, ne? So
Äh, ich glaube halt
Livestream is sponsored by Activision, ja
Achso, ich lasse mal den Chat eingeblendet, oder?
Steven Seagull, genau
Ok, also wir machen dann den Stream groß, hier, hier, hier, hier
Je nachdem, wer am interessantesten aussieht
F11, ja, hatte ich doch schon
Kurz was gucken
Ok, ich mein, solange die noch labern und ich mein, aktuell sieht man nicht viel außer, dass sie laufen
Können wir uns eigentlich nochmal angucken, was das Main-Pod für tolle Sachen hat
Wir lassen, wir planten es einfach so ein, dass wir sehen, wenn es losgeht
Das ist das neue Kot, ja, heute ist das erste Mal, wo man richtig Gameplay sieht
Aber solange die da einfach nur rumlaufen, dann
Kann ich mir nochmal das Main-Pod in Ruhe angucken, warum das jetzt so teuer ist
Die machen hier gerade ihr Intro-Stell
Ist das der Ernst von Gigabyte, oder?
Thermal Reactive Armor Design, das hört sich an wie eine Panzerung bei irgendeinem Tank
Direct-Touch-Heat-Pipe-N-Nano-Cap, ok, es ist einfach nur Gelaber, warum es das jetzt so teuer macht und warum man das bezahlen soll, das erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht
Oh, sie haben einen USB-Charger dran, krass, das kriegt man ja ohne 800 Euro nicht
RGB-Fusion
Das ist doch kompletter Blödsinn, 800 Euro für so ein Main-Pod, äh
Das ist doch kompletter Blödsinn
Best an die Main-Pod ist ja tatsächlich noch der USB-Turbo-Charger
Oh, was jetzt? Ok
War das gerade, das war die Animation auf der Seite hier, oder?
Ok, wenn man sich, sie sind hier schon super excited, wie sie hier abgehen
Wahrscheinlich ist das eines der am häufigsten, das sieht aus wie Killbox von Cod 4
Das ist original Killbox, oder?
Ok, wirklich einen Sound hören tun wir eh nicht
Ok, es sieht aus wie ein Cod, ja
Die Farmas ist anscheinend wieder, ähm, Tap, Burst
Warum, warum, WTF, warum
Ach, das ist quasi Two-on-Two ohne Respawns, oder wie?
Hm, weiß nicht
Two-on-Two ohne Respawns und ohne Objectives
Oder gibt es ja irgendwie Objectives außer Kille deine Gegner komplett
Ja, ja, genau, das ist die Cod 4 Map
Man kann wieder Sliden, das finde ich gar nicht schlecht, dass man Sliden kann
Schaut aus wie ein Free-To-Play-China-Klon, ähm, muss ich dir jetzt so das was man sieht recht geben, ja?
Das ist aber wirklich Resident Sleeper, ich dachte man sieht, ok die MP5 sieht wenigstens schön wieder nach MP5 aus
Generell sieht das übelst nach Cod 4 aus, aber es ist halt nicht Cod 4
Also was aber kein schlechtes Ding unbedingt ist
Ein ordentliches Modern Warfare Cod wäre wirklich eine Sache, was mich begeistern könnte
Tencent Game, ja es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein China Free-To-Play-Shooter, das stimmt schon
Aber der Spielmodus ist nicht schön zum Zeigen vom Game
Erstmal schön weggenubtubt
Animationen sehen merkwürdig aus, ja wahrscheinlich haben sie noch nicht genug Animationen zum Recyceln gefunden und es fehlen noch ein paar
Es scheint ja ultra-taktischer Modus zu sein, ja?
Huge Taktik
Wollte ich gerade sagen, warum zeigt man so ein Spielmodus, ich weiß nicht
Also der Spielmodus und die Map erscheinen mir irgendwie nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, äh, um was zu zeigen
Was meint ihr, wie viele Leute im Twitch Chat, also nicht bei mir, aber bei den offiziellen Channels, jetzt schreiben, dass da ein Grill im Hintergrund ist
Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder Twitch Chat Deluxe wieder angesagt
Grill, OMG, RL Grill
Grill
Monka Grill
Also der Spielmodus und die Maps sind irgendwie ziemlich doof zum Zeigen
Ähm, gibt's da irgendeine, habt ihr irgendeine taktische Komponente erkannt, also sowas wie, zum Beispiel, dass man nur spezielle Klassen einmal spielen kann, bis man alle weg hat
Oder dass man irgendwie Equipment kaufen muss oder sowas
Für mich sah das ganz normal aus, klasse, klasse, auswählen und drauf
Oh, ist das, das ist Random Loadout, hä?
Ah, Random Loadout
Face im Stream, ja, ich, ich jebaite ja manchmal die Leute im Stream ganz gerne, aber so hart jebaiten
Warum geht eigentlich hier diese Sachen, dieses Overlay nicht weg, ich hab doch den Mauszeiger extra in der Mitte drin
Ah, jetzt, ok
Ich hoffe die zeigen doch ne ordentliche Map
Oh, dieser Fake Hype immer in den, in den, in den, bei den ganzen Let's Play Dudes da
Meint was? Der hat rüber geschossen
Das war doch niemals ein Hit, ey
Ok, anscheinend sind Sniper nicht immer One Hit
Genau, Hardscope Noob, ey
Sorry sieht nicht so geil aus, du musst nicht Sorry sagen, du hast Recht, der sieht nicht so geil aus
Ähm, allerdings muss man das mal abwarten, insofern, ich wei, wir sehen hier quasi irgendwie den sehr merkwürdigen Spielmodus auf ner sehr merkwürdigen Map
Für nen Stream, wo man was Neues zum Game zeigen will
Oh, jetzt kommen mir die krassen Wallbang Skills hier
Equipment Unavailable
Kriegt man, kriegt man verschiedene Sachen nach ner Weile?
Ja, ich hoffe auch, dass sie noch nen gescheiten Spielmodus zeigen
Ah, Remington, Dink's Game
Ah, Remington, Dink's hier, wie hieß das Ding? 1882 oder so, gab's in, hatten's in Black Ops auch
Ein nice Shotgun
Ton gemutet? Ja, ich entmute mal kurz, ich will mir den Fake Halt mal kurz anhören
Oh, Concentrated sind sie
Ok, ich mute wieder
Super, eben war's so
Oh, das Grill ist weg, oh ne
Komm, wir gucken mal bei nem anderen, der spielen kann
Ähm, wer kann, kennt die jemand, wer kann denn am besten spielen von denen?
Ich kenn bloß Syndicate von denen
Wer, wer ist Syndicate hier vorn?
Welcher Stream ist Syndicate?
Ach da, muss mal hochscrollen, der da, das ist Syndicate
Na, der hat, der hat seinen RTX nicht on, würd ich sagen, bei der Stream-Quali
Was geht denn da gerade ab?
Wir sind keine Zwölfe am Axe, warum nicht?
Woher soll ich, woher soll ich das wissen?
Nein, ich meine welcher Stream Syndicate ist
Syndicate ist der Einzige, der in der Name, der mir was sagt
Moment, warum ist das wieder da?
Ach, hatte ich die ganze Zeit Syndicate offen oder was?
Ok, dann äh
Weißt du nicht, wie Syndicate aussieht, ich kenn den Namen bloß
Ähm, wer soll das Team, das hier gerade ist?
Die da, der da, äh, die gewinnen, den muss ich mal angucken
Winning Team Joiner
Warum schreien die alle so äh
Soll das jetzt, sind die super, super immersed in das Team?
Soll das jetzt, sind die super, super immersed in dem Game oder?
Alter, ich geh mal fort
Was da los, warum schreien sie so?
So
Wirechamp, ja
Ok, viel erkennt man ehrlich gesagt nicht
Man erkennt, dass es altbekannte Waffen gibt, es gibt eine Famaaas
Oder eine Famaaas, wie der Fabian immer gesagt hat
Es gibt, ähm, diese komische Black Ops 1, Shotgun
Es gibt die üblichen Sachen aus Samtags, Stun, Flash, Gedöns
Man kann die Granate jetzt mit links werfen
Weil das wahrscheinlich auch in echt super akkurat wäre
Einfach mal nebenbei, so die Flashbangs
So wisst ihr, wisst ihr, ich stell mir das grad vor
Wir sind in irgendeiner Übung und der Dude kommt da an mit seiner Famaaas im Anschlag
Und wirft dann einfach mal so richtig casual mit links so das Flashback so aus dem Handgelenk
Äh, Flashback aus dem Handgelenk
Ey Leute, Flashback hier, flupp
Oder irgendwie
Gibt's ja genug Failvideos, wo es bei irgendwo, wo wirklich die, die Bros ähm, irgendwelche Übungen machen
Und Flashbacks gegen die Wand hauen und sowas
Äh, gibt's ja genug Military Failvideos auf YouTube
Da sind auch nicht, die werden auch nicht als Profis geboren
Erstmal schön, schön genubtupt, genau
Ey, du musst dir das nur, nur, wenn du dir das ohne Ton anguckst, du kannst dir das rumgeschreit sogar direkt vorstellen
Is Call of Duty dead
Das hat ein bisschen was von der Aim, von der Aimtraining Map
Ähm, nur ohne Aimtraining Ziele
Epiketrickshot
Zeigt's heute noch Discord?
Oh ja, könnt ich machen
Ist da Sebaro oder der Patrick am Start?
Warum stehen so viele Leute im Hintergrund?
Die Frage ist eher, warum stehen so viele Leute im Hintergrund?
Es sieht aus wie bei irgendwie einem
In der Fabrikhalle
Also, wie.
Wo steht der in der Fabrikhalle?
Ist da eine Faust, wo steht der in der Fabrikhalle?
Ja, das ist ein Foto
Das ist ein Foto
Jetzt laufen sie wieder rum. Okay, in der Zwischenzeit wo die, wo die rumlaufen, gucken wir uns mal weiter.
Ups, da kommt der Sound her. In der Zeit wo die rumlaufen, ich hoffe die machen jetzt mal eine ordentliche Map.
Das ist die Cod Recycling, der war gar nicht schlecht. Man hat bisher noch gar nichts gesehen so richtig vom Game.
Ja, bis die, bis die hier fertig rumlaufen sind und hoffentlich eine neue Map anmachen, schauen wir uns mal weiter an, was wir uns für Mainbots holen könnten.
Genau das ist das zweite Mainboard mit, ähm, oh! Das sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie Firing Range, ist es aber nicht.
Äh, äh, du den hatten wir eben. Der hat so ausgelenzt weißer Halbwegs wie das Game. Erstmal, erstmal schön den Energy Booster, Booster Drink promoten.
Okay, das ist so eine Mischung aus Firing Range und, ähm, Kisten.
Deckt. Jetzt, jetzt müssen wir, jetzt müssen wir den Stream switchen können. Äh, jetzt wird hier, jetzt wird hier auch noch shotgun'ed. Geschotgun'ed und gepistelt.
One on one Rust, only quickscope. Okay, die Stream Quali bei dem ist jetzt nicht so geil. Was hatten wir doch gerade schon mal?
Ähm, das ist nur dieser Modus. Das Waffenshaken sieht glaube ich nur in der Killcam so kacke aus. Wie viel hast du für deinen PX ausgegeben? Was für ein PC?
Ähm, keine Ahnung, musst du immer das Video angucken? Ich weiß es nicht. Achso, wie viel willst du für deinen PC ausgeben? Nee, ich hab, also wenn ich das wirklich mache, wenn ich das wirklich mache, dann sollte es eine Möglichkeit unter 1000 sein, weil ich brauche keine SSD, ich brauche keine Grafikkarte eigentlich und ich brauche kein Netzteil.
Ich brauche im Prinzip bloß CPU und RAM und Mainboard. Der hat rekt. Okay, der kann halbwegs spielen, der Dude, den gucken wir uns weiter an. Ist da Hust was? Ey, Erkältung ist so nervig.
Also wenn man den Spawn sieht, der Spawn ist schon mal ein bisschen merkwürdig. Du spawnst direkt gegenüber, also das erste was man normalerweise machen würde in einem Zweier-Team ist, einer flasht, einer nades. Das ist das erste was ich probieren würde.
Durch den Flash können sich die Gegner nicht bewegen und die Granate macht sie platt. Wenn der Spawn wirklich so bleibt. Weil du kannst ohne Probleme die Granate da drüber werfen, so wie es aussieht.
Der erste macht der erste Flash oder Stunt, die Dinger lassen sich ja schnell werfen und dann legst du auch ne Granate hinterher, easy win.
Deswegen sind die Nets in den ersten Sekunden deaktiviert. Dabei, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ob ich das gut oder schlecht finden soll.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das gut oder schlecht finden soll, dass in den ersten Sekunden Equipment deaktiviert ist. Es ist gut, dass man nicht so nen Scheiß machen kann, wie ich gerade gesagt hab.
Es ist eigentlich schlecht für ne Ausrede, dass man die Maps nicht richtig bauen kann.
Könnte man nämlich die Maps richtig bauen und die Spawns richtig setzen, dann müsste man das Equipment auch nicht disablen.
Wie lange geht der Stream schon? 20 Minuten oder so? Also meiner ist schon 2 Stunden oder so. Der Codstream ist erst seit 15 Minuten oder so was.
Ich muss euch aber sagen, weil sich ein paar Leute über die Animationen vorhin lustig gemacht haben, ich find das sieht echt ganz brauchbar aus.
Warum ist die Pistole so schepp?
Ah, das ist ne Map mit Objective, der vorher hatte kein Objective. Wobei das Objective halt auch irgendwie ein bisschen lieblos ist.
Ich mein das ist ne viereckige Map, Spawn direkt gegenüber, 5 Kisten drauf gestellt und ne Flagge in die Mitte.
Das sieht für mich jetzt nicht so nach nem krassen Competitive-Modus aus, der durch die Decke geht.
Ok, habt ihrs gesehen, Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit ist anscheinend bei ner Flash normal, das ist schonmal ganz gut.
Die greifen sich damit alle. Kein Helz-Wreck. Gute Frage. Ich vermute schon das ist ein Helz-Wreck. Ach doch, guck mal oben.
Warum ist hier die Helz-Anzeige? Das müssen wir mal beobachten. Guck mal, die sind jetzt auf 100, weil einer tot ist. Ok, die anderen sind auf 159, anscheinend gibt es keinen Helz-Wreck.
Es gibt keinen Helz-Wreck, das finde ich schonmal gut. Allerdings könnte man das auch wunderbar als Gameplay-Element nehmen.
Das ist eben beispielsweise, also nicht bei so ner Minimap, aber wenn man zum Beispiel ein bisschen größere Map hätte, dann könnte man sagen ok, man macht keinen Helz-Wreck, allerdings an speziellen Punkten gibt es Kisten oder sowas.
Das würde das ein bisschen taktischer irgendwie machen und ein bisschen ausgefeilter, weil aktuell ist es so kleine viereckige Map mit ein paar Kisten drauf, Körbe einrennen gegenseitig bis eine Seite tot ist.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Modus, den weder Call of Duty-Fans gut finden, weil die richtigen Call of Duty-Fans mögen in der Regel sowas wie Team Deathmatch mit vielen Killstreaks, noch die richtigen Competitive-Leute.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie damit beispielsweise Rainbow Six-Spieler oder CS-Spieler abgreifen werden.
Und die richtigen Call of Duty-Fans, die spielen lieber Team Deathmatch TDM-Domination mit vielen Killstreaken, Bashe und ein richtiger Competitive-Modus ist es auch nicht bei 2 vs. 2.
Das müsste dann eher sowas wie 5 vs. 5 oder 4 vs. 4, 6 vs. 6 sein, mit ordentlichen Maps, mit einer ordentlichen Größe und einer ordentlichen Spieltiefe.
Also ansonsten verstehe ich aktuell nicht so ganz, was mir der Modus sagen soll.
Und nice Hitsbox. Ja, aber das ist die Killcam, da kann man nicht viel dran ablesen jetzt.
Die Dudes im Background langweilen sich auch hart beim Zusehen. Das ist, wenn ich mir das so angucke, ja, hast du recht.
Was sagst du zum neuen Cod? Sieht ja schon mal nicht so schlimm aus. Ich kann nichts dazu sagen, also dieser Spielmodus sagt mir überhaupt nicht zu.
Aber man kann aus diesem Stream jetzt wenig über das restliche Game ableiten, weil ich meine die Maps, die man bisher gesehen hat, sind der Witz.
Das ist quasi eine Größe von einer Lagerhalle für jede Map. Also die Maps sind übelst klein, sind auch total gradlinig und ohne großartige Taktik.
Also viel erkennt man in dem Spielmodus noch nicht. Weiß jemand, ob es wieder einen Battle Royale gibt oder ob die Battle Royale in Black Ops 4 lassen und dort weiter supporten.
Da kommen noch große Maps, ja sag ich ja. Man kann sich hier anhand der Sache gar nicht so viel ableiten hiervon.
Wir gucken auf jeden Fall dem Richtigen schon mal zu, weil die gewinnen.
Altes Cod weiter supporten, das könnte ja sein, dass die sagen, wir lassen Battle Royale in Black Ops 4 und verkaufen da weiter unsere Skins und Waffen und Gedöns.
Ich mein, das wäre für die doch cool. Zwei Call of Duty, wo du Geld ausgeben musst.
Aber wirklich aussagekräftig ist es nicht. Was war denn das?
Freue mich auf Battlefield 2020, Christ the Game, dann kann ich dir nur recht geben, vorausgesetzt ist es Bad Company 3.
Und Bad Company 3, was man nicht nur so nennt, sondern was auch ein gewisses Feeling von Bad Company hat.
Ich hab letztens wieder Bad Company 2 installiert, ein paar Runden gespielt, macht immer noch Bock genauso wie früher.
Bisschen schwieriger zu spielen als früher, weil die Leute nicht mehr so koordiniert zur Sache gehen.
Und die Server übelst unbalanced sind, aber an sich macht das Spiel immer wieder Bock.
Hast du Gamestown Quick Runs von den letzten Monaten zu empfehlen? Nein, ich hab diesmal kein Gamestown Quick geguckt.
Ich guck da auch schon seit einer Weile nicht mehr, seit sie angefangen haben Paywall vor den Chat zu machen und sowas.
Will ich eigentlich nicht mehr supporten.
Irgendwie hat das mit dem ursprünglichen Event, finde ich, so einfach Spaß und Zusammensitzen und Speedruns angucken, wenig, wenig noch gemeinsam.
Ich verstehe es, warum sie so machen, ja, letztendlich spenden so mehr Leute, aber ich guck es nicht mehr gerne.
Es gibt doch Hellstrike mit Spritzen.
Ich glaube, es hat jeder, ich gehe mal davon aus, unten rechts wird das sein, also wahrscheinlich hat jeder.
Oder es ist ein Gadget, was man sich ausrüsten kann vorher.
Wenn es ein Gadget ist, was man sich ausrüsten kann, werde ich definitiv Hellstrike mitnehmen.
Wir sehen es jetzt gleich in der nächste Runde, ob es die Spritzen jedes Mal gibt oder ob das random war.
Nee, das ist Gadget, muss man ausrüsten, die Spritzen.
Ich finde das aber prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Bist du da oben rechts?
Ich bin der da, guck, der da bin ich.
Ich hab mich extra so platziert, dass man mich nicht sieht.
Zumindest hat der Typ schonmal einen Bart, also der sieht mir von allen im Stream noch am ähnlichsten.
Auch so vom Bart-Style her, sieht fast aus wie bei mir, und mit der Kappe auch.
Das sieht mir echt gar nicht so unähnlich, wenn ich mir das gerade so angucke.
Spiegels nicht im Screen.
Eine Panzermine gegen, auf einer, denkst du, Teams sind voll.
Ach, es war gar keine Panzermine, das war eine, wir nähern uns und es fliegt in die Luft.
Ich würde mal sagen, die anderen werden ganz schön gereckt gerade.
Die gewinnen haushoch jede Runde.
Nee, das war keine Clamer eben.
Das, was der gelegt hat, war so eine, so eine, eigentlich so eine Mine, die aussieht wie ein Battlefield für Panzer.
Ist das der Deagle?
Aus wie der Deagle, oder?
Bisschen zumindest.
Oh, weil er geflasht.
Get wrecked.
Und trotzdem gewonnen haben.
Wir gucken uns schon die richtigen an, die haben die letzte Map auch haushoch gewonnen.
Ich glaube, der Spielmodus wird nicht überzeugen.
Also, zumindest überzeugt mich der Spielmodus nicht.
Zu wenig das, was die Casual Pro-Fans wollen und zu wenig das, was Competitive Spieler wollen.
Oder was sagt ihr bisher zu dem Modus, den man gesehen hat?
Zum restlichen Game kann man recht wenig sagen, finde ich, bis jetzt.
Außer, dass die Time to Kill relativ niedrig aussieht.
Dass es wohl einen Held-System gibt.
Mit Spritzen.
Langweilig, okay.
Der Modus ist Quatsch, ja, denke ich auch.
Stimmt, die Leute, die haben sich alle verpisst im Hintergrund, will keiner mehr sehen.
Alle weg.
Okay Leute, ich geh noch mal ganz kurz aufs Klo.
Gleich wieder da.
Dann gucken wir uns noch ein paar Ryzen Mainboards an.
Die Coffee Pasta kenne ich ja.
Auch gleich wieder da.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns noch ein paar Ryzenii Games an.
Den troubled
So, oh, da ist die Map.
Moment, nee, welchen Dude hatten wir gerade offen? Den da.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Creak aus Code 4.
Was sollen diese Container überall?
Was haben die mit ihren Containern, ey?
Einfach mal so eine Hütte im Wald mit einem Container.
Ist das so wie Holzkisten in Half-Life?
Was meint ihr? Sind das Maps, die extra für diesen Spielmodus gemacht sind?
Nicht, dass es großartig aufwendig wäre, so eine Map zu machen.
Oder sind das Teile von den eigentlichen Maps im Spiel?
Oder sind das quasi Ripoffs von den eigentlichen Maps im Spiel plus angepasst für diesen Spielmodus?
Die sagen, dass die extra dafür gemacht sind? Okay.
Ja, was nu?
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, es ist im Prinzip so ein Ripoff von der originalen Map.
Man hat die originale Map genommen und sich halt die Texturen, Bäume, Gedöns, alles rauskopiert, was man braucht.
Und eine kleinere Map daraus zusammencopy pastet.
Und ich finde auch ehrlich gesagt, dass die Maps auch ein bisschen nach copy-paste aussehen.
Ich meine, du hast immer einen Container in der Mitte, die sind immer quadratisch, also die sind immer, zumindest rechteckig.
Die spawnen immer gegenüber.
Das Cover ist sogar auch immer relativ ähnlich platziert.
Mal kann man irgendwo hoch, weil ansonsten haben die Maps doch, und vor allem sind sie viel zu klein.
Sie haben ein bisschen wenig Variation. Es gibt eigentlich immer einen links-rechts-mitte Weg.
Gut, das ist prinzipiell nicht schlecht für so Maps.
Also so einen kleinen Kniff wäre doch gar nicht verkehrt bei einem Modus, der eigentlich die Möglichkeiten bieten würde, dass man das ein bisschen taktischer macht.
Sieht man doch, dass das kein Modus ist, den die Leute spielen wollen.
Ja, warum baut man ihn dann ein?
Also wenn man, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man von Anfang an den Modus designt, den man nur einbaut, damit die Leute ihn nicht spielen.
Das wäre ja irgendwie ziemlich Verschwendung von Ressourcen, oder?
Ich werde den Modus niemals, ja ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht, aber sie müssen sich ja irgendwas bei gedacht haben, wenn sie den Modus einbauen.
E-Sport, ja das ist Null. E-Sport ist klar. Das ist Null der E-Sport-Modus.
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal auf Twitter flamen.
Ist ja vollräudig aus, sieht der 2 versus 2 Modus.
Jetzt bin ich geschneibert.
Für private Sessions, ja okay vielleicht, vielleicht.
Was sagt ihr optisch dazu? Ich finde, man kann auf diesen Maps und man kann sogar relativ wenig über die grafischen Qualitäten von dem Game sagen.
Es sieht ziemlich verschwommen aus.
Nicht weil er im Scope ist, aber das könnte auch an seinem Stream liegen.
Es sieht ziemlich verschwommen aus, weil wie gesagt liegt wahrscheinlich am Stream.
Ansonsten sieht man auf diesen Maps Null von den grafischen Qualitäten.
Der Feuer sieht okay aus.
Die Vegetation beeindruckt mich jetzt auch nicht ultra, wobei, was spielen die überhaupt?
L1, R1, ja das ist Playstation.
Also ich würde sagen Leute, wir gucken jetzt die Map noch fertig und dann gucken wir uns noch ein bisschen Ryzen Mainboards an.
Oder was sagt ihr, oder wollt ihr noch weiter gucken?
Ich glaube wir haben alles so ziemlich gesehen, was uns dieser Modus über das Game verraten kann.
Wir haben jetzt drei Maps gesehen, die alle sehr ähnlich sind, auch wenn sie vom Setting her unterschiedlich sind.
Es ist kaum Unterschied zwischen den Maps.
Das Gameplay könnte um einiges taktischer sein, allerdings so wie sie es gemacht haben, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es fehlen auch irgendwie die Kniffe, die es taktischer machen könnte.
Und mir kommt es so vor, als wissen sie nicht so genau, ob sie cut sein wollen oder so eine halb competitive Rainbow Six CSGO Mischung, die aber wahrscheinlich weder CSGO...
Oh, mal einen Weg unter der Map, 2 cm, die aber wahrscheinlich kaum einen Rainbow Six oder CSGO Spieler ansprechen wird.
Ich würde mal sagen, man sollte darauf warten, wie die eigentlichen Maps aussehen und ob sie einen richtigen Competitive Modus schaffen.
Vertical Gameplay, genau, kannst über die Kiste krabbeln.
Ob sie einen richtigen, ordentlichen Competitive Modus eingebaut kriegen.
Oder am besten noch eine ordentliche Competitive Playlist mit passenden Maps, die dazu passen.
Aber ich meine, Call of Duty versucht ja schon seit Jahren so ein bisschen zweigleisig zu fahren.
Ich glaube, sie würden mittlerweile am besten daran tun, entweder sie fokussieren sich mal mit einem Game wirklich auf den Competitive Aspekt.
Und da müsste halt der ganze Mist raus, ja.
Irgendwelche unausweichbaren Sachen, irgendwelche Noobtubes, die zufällig hitten oder sowas.
Wenn dich halt auf den richtigen Competitive Aspekt konzentrieren willst und halt auch die passenden Spielmodus und die passenden Maps dazu.
Ein bisschen wie das CS ja im Endeffekt auch macht.
Oder sie konzentrieren sich das, was Call of Duty letztendlich auch groß gemacht hat, auf Killstreak, Noobgebäsche, bis es keinen Morgen mehr gibt.
Mir würde ja persönlich in den Code gefallen, was ein halbwegs anspruchsvolles Gameplay hat.
Ohne allzu viel Schnickschnack.
Also im Prinzip ein bisschen so, wie man es hier gerade in dieser Runde gesehen hat.
Bloß das ist, also ne, so die Basics.
Du hast deine Primärwaffe, du hast deine Sekundärwaffe.
Und im Endeffekt entscheidet darüber, wer bessere Position hat, wer besseres Aiming hat, wer besseres Mapverständnis hat.
Drüber, ähm, wer die Runde owned und wer nicht.
Also ich, ich würd mir so ein klassisches Call of Duty wünschen mit klassischen Team Deathmatch und, und Domination Maps.
Allerdings mit ein bisschen reduziertem, reduzierten, äh, Gimmickgeschichten einfach nur.
Man könnte, man könnte auch sogar sagen, hey, wir machen bei Killstreaks entweder gar keine oder wir machen die klassischen 3-7, äh, 3-5-7 Killstreaks.
Hast du mal Battalion gezockt, ja? Ja, ja, hab ich.
Also von der Geschwindigkeit im Gameplay her macht das einen echt nice Eindruck.
Ich hab, äh, nur, ich hab nur ganz kurz reingeguckt, als es released wurde.
Ich hab's ja gespielt, als es, als es zum ersten Mal rausgekommen ist.
Oh, vertikales Gameplay wieder.
Erstmal schön liegen und gucken.
RTX Wasser.
Ja, die haben bestimmt auch RTX On auf der PS4, nur für Cod.
Und jetzt versteh ich auch, warum die teilweise so komisch hängen bleiben.
Das ist Konsole.
Ich hab's die ganze Zeit, ich hab's schon fünfmal gesagt, das ist PS4, aber so wirklich, so wirklich kapiert hab ich's nicht.
Das ist ja Konsolengameplay, kein Wunder, dass die teilweise hängen bleiben oder komische Dinge machen.
Da, da kannst du im Prinzip auch nichts gegen machen.
Du kannst halt mit dem Controller nicht gescheit strafen.
PS5 Gameplay.
Okay, die Runde gucken wir noch oder die Map gucken wir noch und dann ist gut.
Die Farben sehen halt nicht sehr nice aus.
Ich glaub, das kann man, das kann man, das könnte auch am Stream und allem liegen.
Da muss man mal gucken, wenn man, guckt mal, sogar das Rot und das, guckt euch mal an, hier unten das Rot und das Blau, das sieht total ausgewaschen aus, das liegt bestimmt am Stream.
Ja, Tata, Stresemann, das ist so, die machen sich da garantiert Gedanken drum, aber dann muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn man halt nix halbes und nix ganzes als Game ist.
Checkt. Also die Farmas als Waffe, das ist so fast das einzige, das spiele ich sechs Jahre von den Waffen, die gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut. Also drei Burst, tot.
Farmas Rote Tigerstreifen, das durfte man doch gar nicht spielen oder, weil Elortrix das immer gespielt hat. Da war mal ein krasser Faker, wenn man Farmas Tigerstreifen gespielt hat.
Oder die erste Penta Nuke, die gefaked war, ne, oder wie war das? Ach, ich hab mir das gar nicht mehr genau gemerkt.
Ja, also der Spielmodus schockt mich wirklich nicht. Denk einfach, das ist irgendwie nix halbes und nix ganzes. Das will ein bisschen auf CS und Rainbow Six machen, ohne irgendwie die Tiefe von CS und Rainbow Six zu haben.
Die Maps sind ultra klein, viereckig und irgendwie immer das gleiche. Quadratisch Container in der Mitte, links, rechts Deckungen dazwischen. Also wir haben jetzt drei Maps gesehen, die sehen alle exakt gleich aus, bis halt auf die Umgebung drum herum.
Und Kniffe in diesem Modus gibt es an sich keine. Es ist lieber Equipment deaktiviert, anstatt die Maps gescheit zu machen.
Also ich weiß nicht. Das sagt mir nicht zu dieser Modus, den ich hier gesehen hab. Gut, ich lass den Stream noch mal kurz weiterlaufen, dass wir uns die vierte Map noch nebenbei angucken können.
Ich will schauen, wie die vierte Map aussieht. Also wir haben die erste Map gesehen, die war der Inbegriff von quadratisch mit Kisten. Die zweite Map, die war auch quadratisch mit Kisten. Die dritte Map war quadratisch mit Kisten im Wald.
Wir gucken, wie die vierte Map ist. Und ich könnte fast vermuten, die vierte Map ist quadratisch und mit Kisten.
Gunfighter King. Moment, heißt der Spielmodus Gunfighter King? Ich dachte es ist ein Titel, den einer gekriegt hat am Ende der Runde. Wahrscheinlich ist die nächste Map, da muss ich iSnaps Recht geben, wahrscheinlich ist die nächste Map quadratisch mit Kisten im Schnee.
Für einen Mainboard entschieden? Nee, haben wir noch nicht. Wir haben uns nur Mainboards angeguckt, die eine 10G-Karte drin haben und die sind hoffnungslos überteuert.
Also wirklich massiv zu teuer. Ich nehme doch kein Mainboard für 500 Euro oder 800 Euro. Wie ernsthaft? Ich sehe es ja jetzt erst. Das Ding ist noch nicht mal online gehostet oder was?
Muss wirklich im Jahr 2019 noch irgendeiner Lobby aufmachen? Sehe ich das richtig? Wollt ihr uns verarschen?
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht drauf geachtet. Gut, dass du das gesagt hast. Oh, wieder die erste Map. Okay, GG. Reicht jetzt, genug. Irgendwo müssen sie halt sparen.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Ich meine Fortnite hat ja nun wohl deutlich mehr Spieler und auch wahrscheinlich ein etwas anspruchsvolleres Surfer-Modell mit wieviel Leuten da auf der Map sind und wie groß die Map ist.
Und da muss auch keiner Lobby aufmachen.
Das hat mir echt überhaupt nicht zugesagt. Was mir gerade so einfällt, die schlägt sich Apex auf Twitch gerade.
Okay, die große Fortnite-Konkurrenz ist es nicht geworden.
Der WoW hat doppelt so viel mittlerweile. Okay, die große Konkurrenz ist es nicht geworden. Allerdings immerhin so viele wie PUBG ungefähr. Wobei die Asiaten stehen halt unglaublich auf PUBG.
Oh, was richtig krass ist, dass mittlerweile LoL und Teamfight Tactics 100k plus hatten.
Dota ist bestimmt ein Event oder große Streamer. Sonst hat es nie so extrem viel, hat immer viele, aber meistens nicht erster oder zweiter Platz.
Also ich muss sagen, von allen Games, die ich wohlgemäß nicht gespielt habe, die ich mir nur auf Twitch angeguckt habe, von allen neuen Games, die ich so gesehen habe bisher auf Twitch, finde ich eigentlich macht Apex noch den besten Eindruck.
Das ist endlich mal wieder ein Game, wo es drauf ankommt, dass man ordentlich spielt. Also ich will nicht sagen, dass es bei PUBG nicht drauf ankommt, das ist anders gelagert, aber das ist einfach ein Game, wo es auf Schnelligkeit ankommt, den Gegner auf der Map ordentlich outplayen.
So wie es hier sieht zumindest für mich aus, für jemanden, der das Spiel nicht gespielt hat.
Guck doch mal nach 10G bei X470. Ja, mach ich. Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen X470? Nee, gibt's keine. Doch einen. Ist das die alte? Moment, was für Plattformen gibt's eigentlich für den Ryzen 3? Ich dachte, dass das die Ryzen 3 Plattform ist.
Da sieht man, was ich für ein Kackknub bin, was das angeht. S-Rock. Ja, das ist ja fast das, was ich hab, bloß halt für Internet. Was ist denn? Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Die Frage ist doch eigentlich, wenn ich den neuen Ryzen auf den Mainboards der letzten und vorletzten Generation laufen lassen kann, dann bräuchten doch die neuen Mainboards erst recht so ein richtiges Verkaufsargument.
Und das Einzige, was ich bisher gesehen hab, sind die PCI Express 4.0 SSDs und so gedürnt. Aber das ist kein Feature für mich, was rechtfertigt, dass das Mainboard 800 Euro kostet.
Ich mein, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, das Mainboard kostet einen Bruchteil von dem und das Einzige, was das wahrscheinlich wirklich als Feature bringt, wo man sich nicht drüber streiten kann, ist wahrscheinlich PCI Express 4.
Ja, aber dieses Spannungswanzler-Upgrade, das braucht doch wahrscheinlich kein Mensch. Zumindest keiner, der seine CPU normal betreiben will. Und auch Leute, die ein bisschen übertakten wollen, brauchen das nicht.
Brauchen alle alten Boards BIOS-Updates? Wahrscheinlich. Ok, wir machen mal 10G weg. Ne, wir machen mal die Mainboards weg. Aber mehr gibt's da auch so nicht.
Ok, ja dann. Ja dann, das waren die einzigen 4 Boards, die wir haben. Ja, können wir noch mal gucken, was es hier gibt. X57. Ja, das ist eigentlich total bescheuert, wenn ich will.
Also, wenn man wirklich einen Streaming-Rechner bauen würde, würde sich das überhaupt nicht lohnen. Das ist richtig, die 10G-Karte für Kupfer kostet um die 100 Euro.
Wobei ich ja vorhin schon gesagt hab, wenn ich jetzt mir kein Board kaufe mit Onboard-10G-Karte, dann mach ich ne SFP Plus-10G-Karte in den PCI Express-Slot rein. Ist einfach billiger.
Ja, also es gibt, sehe ich wie Anon4273, dass es eigentlich keinen Grund gibt, dass es so unglaublich teuer sein muss.
Der Extreme hat keinen Lüfter, aber gut. Also ich glaube, wenn ich mir so ein PC zusammenbaue, dann stört mich ein Lüfter auch nicht. Also ich seh das Verkaufsargument von den 800 Euro Boards nicht.
Okay, was ist denn das günstigste X570-Board? Ja, das sind doch deutlich realistische Reaktionen. 160. Ich mein 160 ist schon ganz schön teuer für nen Mainboard.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist das günstigste. Und 160 oder 170 ist schonmal ne Hausnummer für Mainboards. Normalerweise kostet, normalerweise holst du dir Mainboards für irgendwie 80 Euro oder so.
Ja, kann auch mal. Aber normalerweise ist so 170 so die Grenze, wo ich sag, ey, ist gut. Sag mal, hör plus ich mich links nicht richtig? Oder hört ihr mich auch links nicht?
Es könnte aber meine Erkältung liegen, dass ich mich links nicht richtig hör.
Okay, Smok. Passt alles. Alter, ich glaub, ich muss demnächst mal Schluss machen. Okay, was hat denn das billigste Mainboard?
S-Rock, Phantom Gaming, aber hauptsache Phantom und Gaming.
Der hat auch zwei PC-Express 4. Zwei PC-Express 4 einfach. Hat der auch ne M2?
Ja, easy. Also das wird voll und ganz, voll und ganz ausreichen. Da würd ich das nämlich so machen. Grafikkarte, also sollte ich mir das wirklich holen. Grafikkarte und Netzwerkkarte und Capturecard.
Capturecard reichten einfach, glaub ich. Ansonsten umgedreht.
Passt. Also das wird voll und ganz, wie ist denn eigentlich so die, wie ist denn so die Onboard-Grafik von den Ryzen? Haben die eine? Wahrscheinlich, oder? Das ist AMD. Ich will ja damit überhaupt nichts spielen.
Es geht mir einzig und allein darum, dass man das Ding zum Rendern für Streams und Videos verwenden kann. Hat keine? Echt nicht? Holst du dir dann die 2080 Ti Super?
Das ist die andere Alternative. Also nicht die. Wie viel kosten die? Super. Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein krass teures Ding für 1800 Euro oder so, ne? Kosten die? Also sollte der neue Nvidia-Encoder wirklich qualitativ so viel besser sein, überleg ich mir wirklich, ob ich mir nicht ne neue Grafikkarte hole.
Und das einfach sein lasse mit dem Render, mit dem Streaming-Rechner, weil ich hab ja hier nen Rechner dran, wo ich ja auch meine Bildchen mache und meinen Text-to-Speech und sowas. Ich hab ja nen zweiten Rechner für Vorschau und Chat und alles.
Der braucht halt keine Leistung. Großartig. Einfach nur super, okay.
Das ist ja fast geschenkt, ey. Fast. Scamas.
Bei Ebay. Ja wahrscheinlich bei irgendeinem China-Shop. Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Aber was ist da nicer? Super oder Ti? Ich glaub die Ti ist die schnellste.
Ey, selbst scheiß auf 50 Euro Shipping, aber das ist China-Scam.
Das ist übelst der China-Scam.
Das ist so ein Ding. Das ist sowas, wo sie wieder wahrscheinlich so ne olle Nvidia-Grafikkarte genommen haben und ein anderes BIOS geflasht.
Achso. Einfach nur falsch gelistet, ey. Scamas.
Ja, aber da steht sie als 2080-Ti drinnen.
Ah. G-Baded.
Das ist schon ganz schön teuer. Oder die Alternative wäre, wo wir ja alle was von haben, ich mach einfach mal wieder ordentlich Videos,
sodass ich wieder ordentlich Views bekomme und ordentlich Abos bekomme und ihr ordentlich was zu gucken habt.
Und dann geh ich zu Nvidia und sag Nvidia ich brauch ne neue Grafikkarte. Das wär natürlich auch ne Option.
Aber dazu müsste ich erstmal neue Videos machen.
Okay, das ist schon ganz schön teuer.
Für den Preis krieg ich locker nen saumäßig guten Ryzen-PC.
Wohlgemerkt, ich brauch keine Grafikkarte, ich brauch keine SSD, ich brauch keinen Netzteil und ich brauch kein Gehäuse.
Ich brauch eigentlich nur RAM Mainboard CPU.
Moin, der Katzengott ist da. Was, Schaufenster gucken?
Ja, quasi. Und uns gescampt werden auf Ebay.
Ne gutes X470-Board. Guck mal, was da die günstigen kosten.
Erkältet sein ist wirklich... Ihr kennt das, wenn ihr erkältet seid, gehts euch scheiße und sobald es weg ist, habt ihr vergessen, wie kacke das war.
So, als wär nix gewesen. Oh, Jolo, alles toll, super, war überhaupt nicht so schlimm, alles gut. Und das nächste Mal dann wieder so, voll im Arsch.
800 Euro Mainboard oder 1000 Euro Grafikkarte? Allein schon das im Verhältnis sieht man mal, wie bescheuert ein 800 Euro Mainboard ist.
Ja, und ich find den Preis von der 2080 Ti auch total übertrieben.
Das geht vorbei. Ja, es gibt ja nur die Möglichkeit, es geht vorbei oder ich kratz dran ab. Und ich bevorzuge, es geht vorbei.
Ansonsten wär hier RIP angesagt. Hat letztens wieder einer unter Video gepostet.
Leute, heute stand in der Zeitung, Max ist verstorben oder irgendwie sowas. Das halt, leucht ich dann immer, das ist doofes Gelaber.
Sado sagt, er braucht sein PC zum zocken und AutoCut. Ja, dafür hab ich ja meinen aktuellen Rechner schon.
Ich suche jetzt eigentlich nur einen Rechner, wo ich ordentlich rendern kann drauf.
Ein Rechner, wo ich den nicht als Vorschau rechne für Vorschauen von Streams und Videos und ein bisschen Management Zeug verwenden kann.
Sondern was weiß ich, Followers gucken, Donations gucken, Text-to-Speech machen, Emotes einblenden und bei der Gelegenheit könnte der halt auch rendern.
Der braucht keine ordentlich Grafikkarte. Achso, hast gefragt, ob sich eine Radeon VII lohnt.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber hier sind wir doch in deutlich realistischeren Regionen, oder?
Was übrigens schon witzig ist, dass eigentlich kein Mainboard mehr auskommt.
Ohne Gaming, ohne Plus, ohne Master, ohne Pro, ohne Premium, ohne Ultra, ohne Plus Gaming, Pro Gaming, Gaming, doch Biostar.
Aber Biostar ist totaler Crap. Biostar kaufe ich nicht.
Gaming, Pro, Carbon, Aeros, Gaming, Gaming, iGaming, Strix Gaming, Touchy, ok, die kommen ohne aus. Gaming, Wreck, die haben die neue Boards.
Ach, ich könnte mal, sollen wir mal upgraden.
Nein, Schwachsinn, mach ich nicht. Ich will den abschaffen, ich will den nicht upgraden.
Aber die haben bestimmt 10G, oder?
Intel hatte auf dem Serverboard schon vor vier Jahren 10G.
Netzwerk, wo ist Netzwerk?
Warum abschaffen, weil das Ding viel zu viel Strom braucht?
Es braucht zwar für einen 4HE-Server mit drei Platten und Geduldstrennen nicht viel Strom, allerdings insgesamt braucht es viel zu viel Strom.
Was? Klar, die Intel Serverboards haben schon seit Jahren 10G.
Also die für den Heimengebrauch erschwinglich sind und auf jeden Fall, und die sind auch in der CPU drinne.
Oder? Doch, die waren ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaube so einen habe ich.
Genau, das ist in meiner Sauberkiste drinne, acht Cores.
Genau, und die haben eine Intel X.
Kurz noch abkratzen.
Und die haben eine 10G-Karte drinne.
Sogar zwei, dualport 10G.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass AMD das...
Steht hier überhaupt irgendwas?
Aber es sind auf jeden Fall keine SFP-Plus-Ports, also sind es wahrscheinlich eher 1G-Ports.
Seht ihr irgendwas?
Nee, ich will es mir nicht kaufen, Michi, es interessiert es einfach nur.
Ja, okay, das ist ja doof.
Was empfiehlst du als Home-Server für Home-Assistant und selbst gebasteltes Gedöns mit Linux als OS?
Selbst gebasteltes Gedöns nicht.
Ich würde da jetzt keine Archlinux oder so nehmen, wo ich noch viel selbst kompilieren, selbst bilden, irgendwie selbst konfigurieren muss.
Ich habe einen Ubuntu-Server drauf auf meiner Home-Assistant-Kiste.
Also meine Home-Assistant läuft auf einem...
Vergess immer, wie das Board heißt.
Auf einem Gemini-Lake-Board mit vier Kern.
Genau, da läuft mein Home-Assistant drauf.
Das Board gibt es mit ein paar unterschiedlichen Abwandlungen, aber so im Kern darauf läuft mein Home-Assistant.
Das ist billig, kostet irgendwie 70 Euro, hat eine CPU drauf, ist passiv gekühlt.
Für Home-Assistant super.
Besser als den Raspberry in dem Fall, weil der Raspberry ist für Home-Assistant doch ein bisschen lahm.
Vor allem wenn du neu startest, dauert es ewig.
Ja, und ich würde Home-Assistant halt in dem Fall ganz normal unter Ubuntu-Server installieren.
Mit ihrem, die haben ja so einen Installer.
Der installiert ihr dann glaube ich einen Docker und ein paar Container von ihnen.
Und dann läuft es, das ist eigentlich ziemlich easy.
Du hast dann auch einen Web-Interface zum Managen von dem ganzen.
Also ich würde den Has-Io-Installer auf Ubuntu-Server nehmen.
ClockXHD, ja stimmt, stimmt, nicht Ubuntu.
Sondern wie die coolen Leute sagen, Ubuntu, Ubuntu.
Die routen auch ihr Ubuntu.
Das Ding heißt wirklich Has-Io, ja.
Has-Io.
Was auf Deutsch natürlich doof klingt.
Aber für Home-Assistant jetzt irgendwie wieder passt, ne.
Biostar kaufen wir nicht, Biostar ist crap.
Was für RAM würdest du dir holen, 3002 oder doch?
Das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Nehm das, was preisleistungsmäßig am besten ist.
Wobei, mach keinen Unterschied, nehm ich es zurück.
Bei AMD ist das wohl wirklich messbar, der Unterschied.
Aber ich will sagen lassen.
Also bei Ryzen, bei Ryzen System muss die RAM-Frequenz
wohl tatsächlich bisschen was ausmachen.
Bei Internet ist es nahezu wurscht.
Aber bei Ryzen muss es wohl relativ viel ausmachen.
Ja, dann würde ich bei Ryzen wahrscheinlich 3600 holen.
Ehrlich gesagt, mich aber zu wenig mit beschäftigt.
Aber wir sind jetzt mal hier in Boardregionen, die doch halbwegs okay sind, ja.
Da kann ich mit leben.
Mit so einem Ding, das wäre doch in Ordnung, ja.
Warum es auch immer Gaming Plus sein muss, ist mir eigentlich egal.
Ja, wie es heißt.
Ihh.
Und das von der Seite, das kannst du gern lesen.
Okay, was haben wir denn drinnen?
Wir haben genug PCI-Express-Anschlüsse.
Können wir Grafikkarte.
Capture-Karte. Lass mal Karte reinmachen.
Die PCI-Express einfach brauchen wir nicht.
Ähm.
Es hat einen optischen Sound-Ausgang.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die will ich haben.
Ein Gaming-Device-Port.
Was ist das?
Wo ist der?
Was ist das? Drei.
Alter, das ist ein PS2-Port. Wollen die mich verarschen?
Mit Gaming-Device-Port, ey.
Was ist ein PS-, das ist ein stinknormaler Uralter.
Letztes Jahr 1000 PS2-Port.
Gaming-Device-Port, Alter.
Das ist ja schon relativ hochgegriffen.
Gaming-Device-Port, oder?
Ich finde es ja schon mal beeindruckend, dass ein Board...
Übrigens, ziemlich schlecht freigestellt hier das Ganze.
Ich finde es ja schon mal beeindruckend, dass ein Board 2019 überhaupt noch ein PS2-Port hat.
Hat von euch noch überhaupt jemand irgendwas, was da drin ist?
Nein.
Ich finde es schon mal etwas, was da dran anschließen kann.
Also ich müsste irgendwo noch eine alte Tastatur haben mit PS2.
Die hat sogar Beleuchtung.
Aber nur so eine billige Beleuchtung zum einen ausschalten.
Da müsste ich aber erst mal suchen, wo die überhaupt ist.
Ansonsten habe ich eigentlich nichts, was da dran geht.
Und auch kein Gaming-Device.
Das ist aber toll, das ist ein PS2-Port.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich meine, es schadet nichts, ja?
Also ob ich es jetzt wirklich als Gaming-Device-Port verkaufen würde, weiß ich nicht.
Golden Audiojacks.
DDR4 Booster.
Würde ich auf jeden Fall erst mal ausschalten.
Weil ich glaube, ich würde es jetzt wirklich als Gaming-Device-Port verkaufen.
Weil nichts ist nerviger als RAM-Fehler.
Zwei Power-Connectors.
Das ist jetzt ein Vorteil.
Vor allem, wo sind die Power-Connectors?
Da.
Was ist das denn für ein abgedrehter Power-Connector?
Das ist ein 8-Pin, ein 4-Pin und ein 26, oder was das normale ist, ne?
Das ist der normale ATX-Stecker.
Der normale ATX-Stecker.
Und dann braucht man noch, nochmal, ein 6-Pin und ein 4-Pin.
Wahrscheinlich ist es optional.
Wahrscheinlich reicht es auch, wenn man es einfach hier dran anschließt oder eins von beiden.
Naja.
Oder vielleicht, vielleicht ist das auch extra für Pizzi Express.
Dass sie irgendwie mehr, mehr Strom über Pizzi Express machen. Was weiß ich.
Brauche ich auf jeden Fall für einen Streaming-Rechner nicht.
Oh, es leuchtet.
Hab ich drauf gewartet. Leuchtet.
Die 12 Volltrails gehen zur Pizzi Express-Slot.
Ah, okay. Das heißt, man muss hier was einstecken, dass es angeht.
Gibt gerade eine Aktion bei MSI und bekommt X570-Mainboards eine All-in-One-Wasserkühlung mit der CPU gratis dazu.
Mag nice sein, aber ich bin kein Fan von Wasserkühlung.
Zumindest auch nicht für den Streaming-PC nebendran.
Personalized-Game, okay. Blablabla.
Also das Mainboard würde voll und ganz ausreichen, ja.
Ähm, für meine Zwecke.
Einfach das billigste, das billigste, äh, billig 100, 12 Euro.
Der Eichler. Meinst du wirklich?
Ich mache einen Link im Stream aus, wo Virgin drin vorkommt, schon im Titel.
Also, ich mache keine Streams, auch wo Virgin drinnen steht.
Das ist korrekt, ja.
Hast du eine Möglichkeit, das Bier zu updaten, ja?
Es ist safe, ich habe es mir gerade angeguckt.
Ja, PS2 hat schon seine theoretischen Vorteile, aber heute kriegst du auch kaum ordentliche Hardware für PS2.
Geschweige denn, wenn du was Neues haben willst für PS2.
Wir sehen ja.
Ach ja, übrigens habe ich euch erzählt, mein Winners-Update hat funktioniert, ne?
Oder wo sieht man überhaupt, ob die aktuelle Winners-Persion läuft?
Äh, da? Wo sieht man die aktuelle Winners-Version?
WinFair, ah, die Winners-Bros sind am Start, ja.
License zu Winners-User.
Ja, hier guckt, das Update hat funktioniert.
Das letzte Mal habe ich ja gesagt, ey, ich muss mir eine neue SSD bestellen.
Ich habe mir blöderweise eine neue SSD bestellt, die liegt jetzt hier.
1T 1TB NVMe SSD.
Und danach habe ich festgestellt, das Update lässt sich doch installieren.
Ja, da hatte ich ja diesen dämlichen Fehler das letzte Mal.
Ich weiß nicht genau, woher er gekommen ist, aber ich weiß, wie ich ihn gefixt habe.
Bisher war es so, wenn man seine Festplatte verschlüsselt hat, musste man die vor jedem Winners-Update entschlüsseln.
Winners-Update machen und wieder verschlüsseln.
Weil Microsoft die Treiber nicht drin hatte für das Programm.
Also habe ich das diesmal so gemacht wie immer.
Ich habe meine Platte entschlüsselt, wollte Winners-Update starten, Winners-Update geht nicht.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, ey, scheiß drauf, du hast jetzt eh eine neue SSD bestellt.
Machst du wieder Vollverschlüsselung von der Platte an, falls du die SSD wegschmeißt oder so.
Habe ich euch das letzte Mal erzählt, ich kann es prinzipiell nur empfehlen, die Platte standardmäßig zu verschlüsseln.
Dann hat man, muss man sich auch keine Gedanken mehr machen, wenn man das Ding mal irgendwie in die Mülltonne pfeffert, dass da noch irgendwie was drauf ist.
Und aktuelle CPUs sind so schnell, mittlerweile Encryption, Decryption, das macht da jetzt keinen Unterschied.
So und habe ich mir gedacht, gut, verschlüsselst du den Kram einfach wieder.
Geht relativ schnell, auf der NVMe ist das D irgendwie 30 Minuten wieder komplett verschlüsselt.
Und dachte ich mir so, nachdem ich es mit Veracrypt wieder verschlüsselt habe, das System Laufwerk, dachte ich mir, ey komm, machst du noch mal Winners-Update?
Noch mal Winners-Update gemacht, lief durch.
Also genau das Gegenteil vom letzten Mal, anscheinend haben sie jetzt nämlich die Veracrypt-Driver in Windows drin.
Das heißt, man kann als Veracrypt voll verschlüsselte Systemplatten Windows updaten, ohne entschlüsseln zu müssen.
Das ist natürlich Massive Pock.
Und gut zu wissen, warum natürlich das Update nicht lief, obwohl es entschlüsselt war, verstehe ich nicht.
Aber jetzt lief's.
Ja und jetzt könnte ich das neue Windows-Terminal installieren.
Ja und die große Preisfrage, die sich mir stellt, ist natürlich auch noch, jetzt wo ich, jetzt haben wir uns jetzt die Mainboards rausgesucht.
Also wir wissen schon, das billigste Mainboard reicht.
Die Sache ist doch auch viel eher.
Was für eine CPU holen wir uns eigentlich, oder was würden wir uns denn für eine CPU holen?
Für einen Streaming-Rechner.
Kann man schon auf Ryzen 3 filtern, irgendwie?
Die 12 Kern, prinzipiell würde ich sagen, mehr Kerne für Encoding auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, ja.
Aber es ist halt die Frage, muss ich mal preisleistungsmäßig gucken.
Okay, was ist denn der günstigste?
Ah, ist schon sortiert gewesen.
Okay, der günstigste ist ein 3600.
Wohlgemerkt, das was da aktuell drin ist, ist auch gar nicht so schlecht, ne, in meinem zweiten Rechner gerade.
Da ist hier ein Xeon S31V3 drinne.
Der ist auch nicht schlecht.
Der ist zwar von 2014, aber wie wir ja alle wissen, hat sich da die letzten Jahre nicht allzu viel getan.
Also der ist auf jeden Fall für so ein Rechner, wenn ich nicht encoden will, absolut ausreichend.
Und selbst fürs Encoden ist da ausreichend, wenn ich nicht gerade 1080p 60fps mit Mittel bis High encoden will.
Echtzeit.
In meinem Hauptrechner hab ich, seit Anfang an, seit ich ihn gekauft hab, so wie ich ihn zusammengebaut hab, einen 8700K drinne.
Das war damals einer der ersten 8700K in Deutschland, der ausgeliefert wurde.
Hyper S.
Und ich hab so geschwitzt, ne.
Die Dinger waren ja nicht lieferbar, als die rausgekommen sind.
Und das erste, was ich gemacht hab, ist das Ding geköpft.
Und hätt ich den geschrottet beim Köpfen, wären nicht nur, ich glaub 400€ oder was es damals gekostet hat, oder 450€ insgesamt gesetzt gewesen,
sondern ich hätte mir wahrscheinlich vorneweg drei Monate bis halbes Jahr keine neue CPU kaufen können, weil es keine gab.
Das war echt, zum Glück nicht Smoke.
Das hat zum Glück alles funktioniert.
Aber ich hab echt geschwitzt, wo man da mit der Kreditkarte auf dem Trägermaterial den Gummi abkratzen muss und sowas.
Ne, ich hab zumindest in einem Video von der Bauer geguckt, wie das prinzipiell funktioniert mit dem Köpfen.
Der köpft ja alles.
Der hat ja eigenes Köpftool nach ihm benannt.
Deswegen ist die Sache, meine CPU ist ja gar nicht so mies.
Das heißt, so das Wahnsinns-Upgrade, ist das hier gar nicht?
Da müsste ich also schon mal mindestens einen Achtkern nehmen eigentlich.
Der Bauer ist komplett insane.
Vor allem, das Gute ist, der kann damit auch noch Geld verdienen. Also das ist eigentlich die beste Kombination.
Aber ich finde die Videos auch gut von ihm.
Ich guck mir immer wieder welche an, wenn es um so Sachen geht wie CPU-Köpfen,
oder welche Wärmerleitpaste ist die beste oder sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, der Unterschied.
So, das sind die Achtkerne hier.
Also der hier ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen teuer.
Die 12 Kerne sind mir ein bisschen teuer.
Und eigentlich auch oversized.
So, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem 3700 und einem...
Nur das bisschen Takt?
Kann doch gar nicht sein, oder?
Boxed? Boxed.
Die Verlustleistung muss ja höher sein.
Ja, aber...
Dann würde ich doch lieber probieren, mir den zu holen und mit meinem Super Gaming Ultra Hyper HDX Board
einfach den Takt ein bisschen höher zu machen.
Dann hol ich lieber so einen hier.
Okay, dann sind wir jetzt bei ungefähr 500 Euro.
Das ist ein bisschen weniger.
460 Euro so in dem Dreh mit dem Board.
Dann gucken wir einfach mal, was aktuell der RAM kostet.
Übertacken geht kaum, ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich unbedingt übertacken müsste, ja.
Ja gut, aber der da wird wahrscheinlich mit ordentlicher Kühlung mindestens gehen auf das,
wie der hier Stock läuft, oder?
Da müsste man schon sehr viel Pech haben, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Also von 3,6 auf 3,9 wird doch in der Regel gehen, weil man ordentlich einen Kühler drauf macht.
Ach so, einen Kühler.
Oder wir machen keinen Kühler drauf, keinen ordentlichen und nehmen einfach den Box Kühler.
Der im Vergleich zu Intel bei Box wenigstens ein Kühler dabei ist.
Die High-End CPUs bei Intel, die haben zwar Box dranstehen, ist aber gar kein Lüfter mit dabei.
Trident Z RGB RAM.
Ja, habe ich glaube ich in meinem aktuellen drinne.
Unsinnigerweise.
Der steht unterm Tisch so, dass man noch nicht mal durch die Scheibe reingucken kann.
Ok, gucken wir mal was RAM aktuell kostet.
Arbeitsspeicher.
Speicher.
DDR4.
Speicher. DDR4.
Und dann bitte keine Mini-Bauweisen, sondern normaler RAM.
Solange du keine Samsung B-Dies willst, ist RAM sehr günstig.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was B-Dies sind.
Ich vermute mal, dass das so ein bisschen wie bei SSDs irgendwie besonders widerständsfähige Speicherzellen sind oder sowas.
Obwohl RAM hat keine Zellen in dem Sinn.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was B-Dies sind.
Overclockers Favorite.
Brauche ich nicht.
Ok, gucken wir mal. 16G.
Oh, das ist ja...
Es kann ja sein, dass das letztes Jahr richtig günstig geworden ist.
Ja.
Das ist richtig...
Oh, das ist ja nice.
Weil ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wo ich den letzten Rechner gekauft habe, war RAM saumäßig teuer.
RAM-Preisentwicklung.
Haben wir mal die letzten...
Palette-Preise?
RAM-Preisentwicklung.
Ich würde gern mal die letzten drei Jahre sehen.
Um...
Was meint...
DDR.
Drei, vier, da.
Ich würde es gern mal länger sehen.
Memory-Preises von 1957 zu 2019.
Aha.
Ok.
Geh auf Kurve alles.
Wir hatten, glaube ich, nur ein Jahr gerade, oder?
Wo ist hier Kurve alles?
Oder gibt es diesen RAM einfach nur erst ein Jahr?
Nee, ich kann hier... Oder wo ist alles?
Preisentwicklung öffnen.
Ah.
Aha.
Verstehe.
Oh, hier war massiv teuer.
Aber mein Rechner ist doch älter.
Wann habe ich den gekauft?
Das war doch schon...
Ende 2017 war das.
Ja.
Genau.
Das war nämlich genau hier, wo der Scheiß ultra teuer war.
Schaut euch das mal an.
Das hat...
Hier so habe ich den Rechner gekauft.
Das kostet jetzt einfach nur mal...
Quickmaps.
80, 60, ein Drittel ungefähr.
Super Quickmaps.
Da könnte ich doch jetzt eigentlich gerade noch mal 16G zusätzlich in meinen Rechner schmeißen.
Aber ganz ohne Spaß, wie der Assi Tony da früher gesagt hat.
Ohne Spaß, Leute.
Ich meine 16G sind 16G, aber ich meine...
Ich meine der Kram kostet 55 Euro.
Was kosten die Module, die ich habe aktuell?
Wie oft habe ich jetzt eigentlich schon Rechner eingegeben?
Moin.
The Hook.
Also einmal RGB-Ram, immer RGB-Ram, ist klar, oder?
Blahblahblahblah...
Der da, ne?
Das ist meiner.
Ah ne, das ist ein 32G-Kit.
Das da ist meiner.
Warum ist der so teuer?
Weil RGB-Ram, hä?
Alter, ist das teuer.
Das kostet das dreifache.
Bist du krank?
Naja, damals war das nicht so.
Das war damals gar nicht so ein großer Unterschied, guck mal.
Ich hab ja sogar einen Geizhalslink, aber der wird geupdatet, ne?
Alter, hab ich damals wirklich 250 Euro für den Ram bezahlt?
Bist du krank?
Ja, ich bin krank.
Mokrasic.
Hab ich damals wirklich...
Hab ich damals ernsthaft 230 Euro für meinen Ram bezahlt?
Na gut, aber das Verhältnis ist schon anders.
Ich mein, guck mal, heute kostet 160 und damals hat es 230 gekostet.
Das ist nicht ein Drittel.
Damals kam mir der Unterschied nicht so massiv vor zwischen normalem Ram und RGB-Ram.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, warum kein RGB-Ram?
Weil...
Keine Ahnung, warum ich RGB-Ram reingemacht hab.
Das ist eigentlich total hängen geblieben.
Ich hab mir ja auch für den Lüfter...
Für den Noctua-Lüfter noch extra so Planten gekauft.
Total bescheuert eigentlich, ja?
Total bescheuert.
Also so ein normaler Ram-Riegel...
Nehmen wir mal auch hier CL14.
Kann man das hier oben irgendwie einstellen? CL?
Timings? Kann man hier oben Timings einstellen?
Ich hab doch keine Ahnung, wie viele Nanosekunden da sind.
Ahja, hier. 14.
14, 14, was hatte ich? 14, 14...
14, 14, 34.
Weil der Ram muss nicht wirklich passen dazu.
Aber es wäre auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
CL14, 14, 32, da.
Äh, 2400? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
1200.
14, 14, 34 hatte ich, ne?
Ja, guckt mal, da relativiert sich das Ganze schon ein bisschen,
was ich damals für den Ram ausgegeben hab.
Ich mein, die kosten jetzt auch 230.
Und damals hab ich, okay...
230, jetzt ist es den 100-Euro-Unterschied, ja?
Aber es ist ein Unterschied.
Ich mein, guckt mal, wenn ich mir jetzt...
Wenn ich mir jetzt noch mal 16G reinstöpseln würde,
dann müsste ich ja auch ein bisschen teureren Ram nehmen.
Sonst wär's ja komplett für die hohle Hand gewesen,
dass ich damals besseren Ram geholt hab.
Auch wenn's wahrscheinlich rein benchmarkmäßig
kaum einen Unterschied machen würde.
GlockxHD, ja, da würd ich sagen Verlosung für den Chat am Start.
Oops, falsch ist die Mode. Verlosung für den Chat am Start.
Ja, gut.
Okay, aber um jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen Sache zurückzukommen,
da wär'n wir doch jetzt ungefähr 500 Euro dabei.
Das Mainboard, der Ram kostet 55 Euro,
das Mainboard kostet 120 Euro,
die CPU kostet irgendwie... was hat die CPU gekostet?
Hab ich wieder vergessen.
Was hat die CPU gekostet?
What?
Äh...
340.
Ja, da sind wir doch ungefähr bei genau 500 Euro.
Das ist doch...
Guck mal, da krieg' ich keine ordentliche Grafikkarte
mit neuem Encoder für.
Das ist ein Drittel von der Grafikkarte.
Max, hast du meinen Reply-Tweet gelesen? Nee, ich hab' noch gar nicht auf Twitter geguckt.
Reply-Tweet zu was?
Also ich seh' keinen Link, den mir einer getwittert hat.
Mein neuestes PC-Tweet von Krieg...
Ach, da!
Ah!
Top, das hatten wir...
Ja, das Video hatten wir uns vorhin angeguckt.
Da hat man leider bisschen wenig Qualität erkennen können.
Da muss ich mich noch mal schlau machen.
Aber zumindest ist es, finde ich...
Also, ich mein' mit 500 Euro bin ich dabei.
Neuer Rechner mit 8 Kern.
CPU und RAM. Mehr brauch' ich nicht.
Gehäuser hab' ich genug.
Wahrscheinlich nehm' ich das R4, wo jetzt der Rechner drin ist.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
SSD, 2 TB SSD ist eh drinne.
Moment, was hatte der damals eigentlich für'n RAM drinne?
Hatte der schon DDR4? Nee, der hat DDR3, ne?
Ah, fuck. Sollte ich das alte RAM noch nehmen können.
Was ist dein Fazit? Ja, es kommt auf die Qualität an.
Kommt auf die Qualität an, wie gut die ist.
Das konnte ich jetzt bei den Bildern nicht so genau erkennen.
Ja, allerdings 500 Euro, wohlgemerkt.
NN-Drops, da ist ja sonst nix dabei, ne?
Keine SSD, kein Netzteil, kein Gehäuse, keine extra CPU-Lüfter.
Das ist ja wirklich nur Mainboard-CPU-RAM.
Was in meinem Fall reicht.
Ich mein', SSD ist da, Netzteil ist da und Gehäuse ist da.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz nicees Upgrade, würd' ich mal sagen.
Gibt es eigentlich direkt Vergleiche?
Versus Ryzen 3000, was war das, 3300?
Hab ich wieder vergessen. 3700X.
Warum ist meine CPU, die ich hab, in diesem komischen Ranking besser als die andere?
Ach nee, Moment. Das ist ein ganz anderes Ranking.
58% schneller?
Ein bisschen wenig.
Wird das, dass das Ding doppelt so viel Kerne hat?
Kommt dann auf die Manchmark an, ne?
Ach, Real-World-CPU-Speed, okay.
Das ist so ein Mittelwert aus wahrscheinlich mehreren Sachen.
Was?
Hä?
Wo?
Also ich fand's jetzt mal, hat's nicht so gut erkannt auf den Bildern.
Den Unterschied.
Also ich fand's schon schwierig zu erkennen.
Außerdem ist es immer schwierig, an Screenshots zu erkennen.
Dann sieht man, wie gut das Encoding ist, wie die Bilder, der Übergang zwischen den Bildern ist.
Und da hast du halt bei Spielen mit viel Vegetation, so wie Pupke, hast du halt oftmals im Gras ziemliches Verschwommenes.
Buy Intel?
Alter! Vier?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Und weil das kein Mensch mehr hat.
Multicore-Mixed.
Das sieht schon mal anders aus.
Das ist jetzt eher das, was ich erwartet habe.
Dann ist das da oben so eine Mischung aus Multithreading, Single-Core-Performance, gut, Real-World-Speed.
Das hat ja auch Sinn. Das lasse ich mir gefallen. Das ist quasi in einem realistischen Anwendungsszenario, dass die CPU nur 60% schneller ist.
Und bei 60% war, sagen wir mal, 2000 bis 2005 vielleicht jetzt nicht viel von einer CPU zur nächsten.
Aber heute sind 60% in der echten Welt gespürte Performance ziemlich viel.
Verkauf deine...
Ja, wenn mir eine 8K dafür gibt, verkaufe ich die alte CPU.
Yacht.
Ach, das ist quasi für die Leute, die mit Prozent-X anfangen können.
Fickmuffs.
Also, Kriegs-Sions, ich gucke mir das auf jeden Fall mal an, weil vielleicht ist eine RTX-Grafikkarte eine Option.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass es sich bei mir lohnt, ist halt die Sache.
Ich habe zurzeit eine 1080 Ti.
Wenn ich upgraden sollte, dann müsste ich halt auch schon gleich auf eine 2080 Ti upgraden, dass ich das irgendwie...
Dass es nicht langsamer wird fast schon, ja.
Also im Prinzip bleibt mir da eigentlich jetzt bloß die Option, einfach mal 1400 Euro auszugeben.
Für wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel.
Deswegen will ich da ein bisschen Zwiegespalten, ob sich das wirklich lohnt.
Die 1080 Ti musste nicht abkühlen.
Kauf einfach noch eine 1080 Ti, das lohnt sich nicht.
Aber easy clap.
Ja, aber viel nehmen die sich glaube ich nicht, Spaßgranate.
Die 1080 Ti zu einer 280.
Was wird denn das sein, 15% oder so, wenn es hochkommt?
Wenn überhaupt 15%.
Ja, ich würde ja Nvidia anschreiben.
Allerdings wird Nvidia sagen, Max, es interessiert sich aktuell keine Sau für dein YouTube-Channel.
Mach mal wieder Videos, krieg mal ein paar Views und krieg mal ein paar Abos.
Dann kriegst du auch wieder eine Grafikkarte von uns.
Und da müsste ich Nvidia sogar Recht geben.
Suche Benchmarks?
Gibt es nicht.
Ich habe keine Benchmarks.
Okay, es ist kein Unterschied.
Es ist kein Unterschied.
Der einzige Unterschied wäre der Encoder.
Das könnte auch sein.
Übrigens, der Stream läuft die ganze Zeit schon über NVN.
Und das Stream sieht richtig gut aus.
Aber es ist halt auch nichts bewegt.
Statische Bilder mit 5 MBit oder so Bitrate zu encoden, das schafft sogar mein Raspberry.
Gut, die Rechenleistung ist jetzt kein guter Indikator für Encoding-Qualität.
Es ist einfach nur länger.
Maurice sagt, Windows-Updates stuck at 100%.
Einfach warten.
Microsoft und Progress-Balken haben es ja nicht so miteinander.
So, ich muss sagen, das Upgrade von der 1080 Ti auf eine 2080 Ti oder einen anderen Rechner
mal upgraden.
Eigentlich ist es ein komplettes Luxusproblem, was wir uns hier angucken.
Eigentlich ist es komplett sinnlos.
Da bin ich eigentlich schon on.
Aber fast 4 Stunden und das, obwohl ich so monka-sick bin.
Man könne sich ja sonst nichts.
Das ist aber eigentlich die falsche Einstellung.
Also ich bin mittlerweile so eher auf dem, ja wie sagt man so, auf dem Trip so.
Ich kaufe mir Sachen, die qualitativ gut sind, wenn das was ist, was ich haben will
und wenn das was ist, was ich irgendwie gebrauchen kann.
Und wenn die teuer sind, ist das okay.
Aber ich bin mittlerweile nicht mehr so fürs sinnlose Geld rausschmeißen eigentlich, weil
muss ich mal überlegen.
Ja, was hast du davon im Endeffekt?
Außer, also bei vielen Sachen kaufst du dir was aus dem Impuls raus, weil du dir denkst,
ey ist bestimmt geil und dann kriegst du das und freust dich mal kurz 5 Minuten, dann ist
wieder gut.
Also eigentlich lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht.
Also am besten ist eigentlich, auch wenn man halbwegs ordentlich was verdient, es ist
jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie übelst viel Kohle kriegen würde oder so.
Ich verdiene halt für Frankfurter IT-Verhältnisse normal.
Ist besser, man schmeißt nicht alles zum Fenster raus.
Gut, bei mir kommt dazu, ich habe relativ viel YouTube-Money noch auf der Bank.
Ich habe hier kaum was ausgegeben, weil ich jetzt seit Jahren schon im Endeffekt so mache.
Ich kaufe mir Sachen, die ich für sinnvoll halte und auch wenn sie teuer sind, aber halt
nicht unnötig.
Also ich würde mir beispielsweise nie einen, keine Ahnung, 150.000 Euro Auto oder so einen
Schwachsinn kaufen.
Würde ich nie machen.
Arbeitest du jetzt wieder Vollzeit?
Ne, mach ich nicht.
Und ich würde mir auch nie was kaufen, was ich jetzt nicht bezahlen kann, es sei denn,
es ist halt irgendwas, was sein muss, was aber in den Preisregionen eigentlich nicht unbedingt
vorkommt.
Es sei denn, es wäre irgendeine Investition in irgendwas, dann ist das was anderes.
Aber das blödeste, was man eigentlich machen kann, ist, privat Geld auszugeben, also unnötig,
unsinnig Geld für Sachen auszugeben, die man gar nicht braucht und mit denen man nichts
anfangen kann im Endeffekt.
So bisschen so, wie wenn ich sage, ich kaufe mir jetzt, es muss ja kein 150.000 Euro Auto
sein, ich kaufe mir jetzt ein 1400 Euro Smartphone.
Das ist komplett bescheuer, das braucht kein Mensch, braucht das und im Endeffekt ist es
auch rausgeschmissenes Geld aus dem Grund, nach einem Jahr ist das vielleicht noch die
Hälfte wert, gut außer iPhones mal ausgenommen, die halten ihren Preis besser, aber selbst
da ist das auch ganz schön viel und die sind meistens nicht viel besser als die bisschen
günstigeren Sachen und man kann mit der Kohle oftmals viel sinnvollere Sachen machen.
Hast du eigentlich, ich habe ein Auto, aber das ist alter Crap, ich habe einen Opel Agila,
erste Ausgabe, das ist komplett oller Mist, den habe ich aber auch schon vor YouTube vor
allem.
Ja und wenn ich mir die Leute angucke auf YouTube, die da der Meinung sind, sie müssen
sich jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, irgendwie ein super fettes Auto kaufen, wobei es gab
doch letztens irgendwie, einer hat sich eine Rolex gekauft oder so, das finde ich gar
nicht so blöd, weil wenn man sich da die richtigen Sachen kauft, kann sich das tatsächlich
rentieren.
Also im weitesten Sinne, ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, aber den habe ich jetzt
ja nicht täglich zu tun, der sammelt Uhren und der hat ein paar Rolex Uhren, hat gesagt,
der sind in den letzten drei Jahren, hat er irgendwie quasi das Doppelte bei der einen
Uhr quasi dran verdient, wenn er den jetzt verkaufen würde, also kann schon sich lohnen,
aber ich habe davon absolut keinen Plan.
Oh Ansage an Commander Krieger, ne Ansage allgemein, man muss sich einfach überlegen, nur weil
man jetzt viel Kohle oder genug Kohle hat, ist das blödeste was man machen kann eigentlich
alles direkt zum Fenster rauszuschmeißen, weil früher oder später wird man davon profitieren,
wenn man ein bisschen Kohle hat und sei es nur, dass man sagt, ey Leute, ich bin jetzt
keine Ahnung, ich bin jetzt 50 oder so, dauert bei mir noch ein bisschen, dauert noch 15
Jahre bis ich 50 bin, aber es könnte auch sein, dass man irgendwann mal 50 ist und halt
nicht alles sinnlos ausgegeben hat und dann sagt, ey Leute, ich bin jetzt 50, mir geht
das voll auf den Sack mit arbeiten und alles und man denkt sich dann so, ey ich mache jetzt
mal einen auf Rentner mit 50, das kannst du nur machen, wenn du genug Kohle hast, wenn
du das überhaupt machen kannst und alle die vorher den ganzen Mist aus dem Fenster raus
geworfen haben und sich dann noch erhoffen quasi mehr oder weniger, weil du gewöhnst
dich ja auch an sowas, mehr oder weniger den gleichen Standard dann zu haben, wenn
sie mal wie sagen sie in Englisch, retiren, die können nie retiren, es sei denn sie sind
halt Millionär und haben sonst wie viel Kohle, die nachwächst, kannst du vergessen, ja natürlich
Dema Reach, du kannst morgen von einem Auto überfahren, während du hast nichts von der
Kohle, es kann dich jetzt auch instant der Blitz treffen, aber in Deutschland die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass du dein Rentenalter erreicht, ist gar nicht mal so schlecht und ich beispielsweise,
ich habe keinen Bock bis, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange muss man jetzt arbeiten, 67, ich
persönlich habe keinen Bock bis 67 zu arbeiten und ich werde auch die Sachen so koordinieren
und planen, wie das Kohlemäßig zulässt, dass ich nicht bis 67 arbeiten muss.
Das weiß ich nicht, 67 Jahre, da ist das Leben doch vorbei, aber es ist doch voll von Arsch.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Berufwamm oder erzähle ich so ein bisschen was, also offiziell nennt
sich das Release Manager, aber das mit Manager ist nicht wirklich so.
Einfach wieder YouTube Money gönnen, das mache ich dann irgendwann, wenn ich dann sage,
ey ich bin jetzt 50, habe keinen Bock mehr zu arbeiten, dann gehe ich in den Renten und
mache nur noch YouTube, easy money, dann mache ich dann Guides, how to, keine Ahnung, wie
der ist mit Release Stellzer, ja also wenn es interessiert was ich mache, gibt es Ausrufezeichen
Beruf, ich kümmere mich darum, dass unsere Systeme mit euer Software versorgt werden
und das ist einmal im Monat, ich muss es nicht nochmal erzählen, mach einfach Ausrufezeichen,
Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Max macht ja nur noch React, ich sag, ich mach das wie Unge, wobei der macht ja mittlerweile
wieder Minecraft, da habe ich irgendwie gefühlt in die Ahnung noch Reacted, aber hast du viel
durch YouTube verdient, mehr als 3k, deutlich mehr als 3k, also ich hab letztens, ich kann
es jetzt nicht erzählen, es ist ja im Prinzip nichts was irgendwie, wo ich unterschrieben
wäre, dass ich das nicht erzählen durfte, also ich hab letztens wieder auf das Konto,
ich hab ein extra Konto gemacht, nur für YouTube Zeug und das einzige was ich bisher
bei dem abgehoben hab ist, oder halt was runtergegangen ist, ist ein bisschen Paypal Zeug wenn ich
gekauft hab, das dürften so über die Jahre sich vielleicht 5-6k oder so Paypal handeln
und aktuell sind 67.000 drauf, also ich hab mit YouTubes ungefähr, würde ich mal sagen
so um die 75k verdient und das ist im Vergleich zu dem was andere Leute in dem Zeitpunkt verdient
haben nichts, das ist der Witz, das ist wenn du dir ein paar größere anguckst, das macht
der eben, ich will nicht sagen also die richtig großen im Monat, aber auch die halbwegs größeren
machen das im Jahr, das ist eigentlich kein Ding, wenn du wirklich zu den bedeutenderen
Channels gehörst und ich weiß auch, es ist total bescheuer, dass mein Geld einfach nur
rum liegt und ich damit nichts mache, ich bin schon die ganze Zeit am überlegen, ich
weiß das geht jetzt von, ja diese Kohle hab ich auch ungefähr, also ich bin jetzt fast
10 Jahre auf YouTube oder 9 Jahre ziemlich genau auf YouTube und die meiste Kohle hab
ich davon in 4 Jahren gemacht und damals war bei weitem noch nicht so viel mit irgendwelchen
Sponsoriengeschichten, mit irgendwelchen Marketingdeals und sonst was, da könntest
du heute deutlich mehr reisen und wie gesagt 75k ist im Vergleich zu irgendwie einem halbwegs
aktuellen großen aktiven Channel ist das nicht viel, also da bewegt sich das eher im
5-stelligen Bereich im Jahr und bei den richtig großen Channels noch deutlich deutlich deutlich
mehr, also was zum Beispiel, sagen wir jetzt Montana Black oder so im Jahr mit YouTube,
das kann ich ja nicht mal abschätzen, da kommt ja alles dabei, da kommt Sponsorgeschichten
dabei, was das größte wahrscheinlich sein darf, wobei ich mir da nicht ganz sicher bin,
wie viel der Donationanteil ausmacht, da kommt, ich weiß nicht ob er Patreon hat, da kommen
zweifelst halt so Dinge dabei wie diese 0815 RefLink Geschichten, Patreon kommt dabei,
Donations, das normale Marketing YouTube AdSense Zeugblock, den du automatisch kriegst, auf
Twitch, die Twitch Subscriptions kommen dabei und jede Menge und das ist das was eigentlich
Kohle bringt, jede Menge Promotion Geschichten und irgendwelche anderen Marketing Aktionen
für irgendwelche, lass es mal, irgendwelche Games, Energy Drinks gedöhnt sein, also das
wird sich deutlich im 5-stelligen Bereich bewegen und auch nicht im niedrigen 5-stelligen
Bereich, ich kann es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht abschätzen bei so großen Channels in welchen
Regionen sich das da bewegt, aber das wird wahrscheinlich sich schon so um im Jahr um
so eine halbe Million, wenn nicht mehr, würde ich jetzt einfach mal so aus dem, also ohne
Steuern bezahlt zu haben, Steuern kommen halt schon noch drunter, aber so eine halbe Million
im Jahr könnte ich mir schon gut vorstellen und ich tippe bei ihm drauf wahrscheinlich
sogar noch eine ganze Ecke mehr, weil er wirklich einer der größten in Deutschland
ist und auch auf vielen Plattformen aktiv, präsent, sich insofern gut verkauft, dass
er, glaube ich Monster Energy Sponsorgeschichte und sowas am Start, das wird auch nochmal
ordentlich Kohle bringen und wenn wir mal international gucken, da die großen, da wage ich es noch
nicht mal irgendwie zu schätzen, wie sich das irgendwie bewegen wird, weil das wird
sich im Millionenbereich bewegen, was da an Kohle gemacht wird, allgemein YouTube und
große Channels. Dema Reach, ja wahrscheinlich ist es sogar noch mehr, das war jetzt so sehr
konservativ geschätzt das Ganze, ja, der verkauft sich auch gut und ist auf allen Sachen
aktiv, also wahrscheinlich noch, wahrscheinlich noch mehr, aber wir können, im Prinzip ist
es eigentlich egal um welchen Channels es irgendwie geht, also du kannst heute in dieser
Richtung, kannst du wirklich ordentlich Kohle machen, allerdings muss man halt sagen, es
ist nicht getan mit, man macht jetzt ein paar Videos oder so, also man muss dann schon wirklich
einen großen etablierten Channel haben und eine Sache ist irgendwie ein bisschen unfair
für alle kleineren, aber das ist nicht nur in dem Bereich so, das ist überall so. Stimmt,
das eigene Merchandise, das habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht, ja das ist mal deutlich
mehr als, ja ja, aber das ist überall so und zwar umso mehr du hast im Endeffekt, umso
mehr kriegst du automatisch auch, also sprich, wenn du klein bist, da musst du dich um jeden
Scheiß prügeln sozusagen, so nach dem Motto, oh kriege ich mal kostenlos ein Game und da
wollen sie von dir schon quasi, dass du ihnen den halben Channel für vermachst, so übertrieben
gesagt, ja, wenn du klein bist, wenn du eine gewisse Größe hast, schleimen sie sich bei
dir den, lecken sie dich ab quasi, also wenn du eine gewisse Größe hast oder in gewisser
Sache irgendwie Alleinstellungsmerkmal heraussticht oder sowas, dann kriegst du automatisch immer
mehr und kannst auch immer mehr verlangen und die Jungs da, die heute diesen Call of
Duty Stream gemacht haben, also ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass sich das bei den
großen auch im 5-stelligen Bereich bewegt, von der Promotion her, wobei ich bei ihnen
halt nicht genau weiß, inwieweit sie nicht eh schon mit Activision unter einer Decke
stecken und jetzt halt nicht einmalig den großen Betrag kriegen, sondern das immer
wieder voneinander profitiert wird, weil letztendlich profitieren ja beide von, ja, die Leute profitieren
von, wenn sie sich gut stellen mit Activision für neuen Content und Activision profitiert
von der Bekanntheit der Leute, also da weiß ich gar nicht, ob in dieser Richtung so viel
Kohle fließt, aber wenn man sich alle Sachen überlegt, was es gibt, wie gesagt, die haben
alle eigene Merch-Jobs, die haben Patreon-Accounts, Donation-Geschichten, Subscriptions, Premium-Subscriptions,
eine Menge andere Marketing, sonst was Promotion-Deals, das, da geht es um richtig Kohle, ja, ja Morris
wurde, na gut Ninja ist halt, Ninja ist halt das eine Extrem, der ist, das ist halt, wenn
du dir so einen Balken angucken würdest von 0 zu 100, ist der halt so ziemlich bei 100,
ja, wenn du Brüste hast und halbwegs gut aussieht, hast du sowieso gewonnen auf Twitch, naja,
also es gibt, es gibt schon relativ viele Channels mit hübschen Mädels, die, sag mal
so, wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, sie haben die Webcam und die Webcam und das Ingame-Fenster
vertauscht, weil normalerweise hast du ja eher Webcam unten links zu einem Viertel vom Bildschirm,
wenn überhaupt und das Game, den restlichen Bildschirm oder einfach nur als Overlay und
die haben halt eher so zwei Drittel Webcam und ein Drittel Game, aber so rein, rein,
rein hübsch sein vor der Webcam, auch das reicht nicht auf Twitch, es heißt nicht,
dass es, dass du gut spielen musst oder so, aber du brauchst schon ein gewisses Talent
dafür, dich passend da zu verkaufen für die ganze Geschichte, einfach nur hübsch aussehen
und sich vor die Webcam setzen wird wahrscheinlich auch keinen Erfolg bringen, kannst dann Badewasser
verkaufen zum Beispiel, was ja gerade voll angesagt ist, habt ihr das gesehen, habt ihr
bestimmt alle gesehen oder, Gaming Girl Badewasser, mein eigenes Badewasser, oh ja, da wartet
die Welt drauf, davon hat jeder gehört, ja denke ich auch, das war ja überall, das ist
aber jemand, die kann sich halt auch extrem gut verkaufen und ich glaube noch nicht mal,
dass das alles auf ihrem eigenen Mist wächst, die hat wahrscheinlich mittlerweile ein ganzes
Team an Analyse, Beratung, sonst was Typen dahinter oder Typen, das war jetzt ja schon
wieder, muss ja nicht nur Typen sein, gleich wieder die Sexistenanzeige raus hier, es können
selbstverständlich auch Frauen gewesen sein in diesem Team, wer war das denn, oh wie heißt
die, Belldelfin oder so, Belldelfin, ja, Game Girl, Badewasser, wie da ist das, naja,
es nimmt schon etwas Groteske Ausmaße an mittlerweile, wobei ich, also bei der kann
ich beispielsweise auch absolut nicht abschätzen, was die verdienen, das wird sich wahrscheinlich
auch im sechsstelligen Bereich bewegen, weil die ist ja wirklich auf allen Ebenen aktiv,
ja, Patreon, irgendwie ihr Merchandise Zeug, ihr Snapchat Kram, wenn du dir überlegst,
dass du da einen Snapchat kaufen kannst, einen Snapchat Add oder einen Snapchat Freund von
ihr sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, wie heißt das bei Snapchat, was edit man bei Snapchat,
weil zumindest, wenn sie dich bei Snapchat edit und du dir irgendwie den Premium Snapchat
haben willst, kostet es 2500 Euro und Dollar und das machen genug, die macht locker mehr
als eine Million, das glaube ich auch, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, wenn das
das einzige ist, was sie kann, weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest kann sie das in dem Fall gut
sich verkaufen, da muss sie jetzt auch gucken, dass die da ordentlich Kohle macht, weil ich
meine, die wird jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwie um die 20 sein oder was weiß ich, 20, 22
oder so, mit 35 will das keiner mehr sehen bei der, also die muss das jetzt machen, wenn
nicht jetzt, wann dann, 19, naja, die kann die macht das noch ein paar Jahre, die muss
das jetzt machen, die kann nicht warten, bis sie 35 ist und vielleicht will die auch nochmal
was anderes machen als Gamer Grill auf Instagram sein, also das beste, was sie machen kann
ist das jetzt, auszuschlachten, bis es nicht mehr geht, da finde ich auch überhaupt nichts
Schlimmes dran, warum nicht, ich meine, es gibt genug Leute, die scheinen darauf abzugehen,
2500 Euro Snapchat zu bezahlen, warum soll sie ihnen das nicht bieten, wenn sie das,
wenn die Leute das wollen, ist ja an sich nichts Verwerfliches dran und ich meine, warum
soll sie kein Badewasser anbieten, scheinen ja genug Leute zu geben, die den Scheiß kaufen,
und ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass das die ganzen 12 und 14-Jährigen sind, ich glaube,
da sind ein paar richtig perverse alte Säcke bei, die sich den 2500 Euro Snapchat holen,
weil als 14-Jährige holst du denn nicht den 2500er Snapchat, ich will gar nicht wissen,
was für Leute da den 2500 Euro Snapchat haben, da ist, da ist Stinksia, da ist angesagt,
wir müssen uns einigen wahrscheinlich, ne, die 12-Jährigen, die kaufen sich eher, wenn
überhaupt, das Einsteigertier oder die laden sich irgendwo bei irgendeiner Torrent-Plattform
oder Usenet oder in irgendeinem Forum oder so, laden die sich die Bilder halt dann so
runter, die 12 und 14-Jährigen, die 12 und 14-Jährigen sind auf Instagram am Start und
liken immer alle schön, sind auf Twitter am Start und sonst wo, aber die, die richtig
Kohle ausgeben, sind wahrscheinlich, vielleicht machen die auch mal ein Patreon oder sowas,
aber die, die die richtig fette Kohle ausgeben für die, für die großen Snapchat-Tiers,
das sind wahrscheinlich, ja, keine 12 und 14-Jährigen, Usenet, ey Usenet ist halt immer
noch ein Ding, ja, bei wem, bei Belldelfin, das stimmt auch, die tut wenigstens nicht
so, als wärs nicht so, ne, du hast auf Twitch jede Menge Mädels teilweise vor der, vor
der Webcam sitzen, wo es halt offensichtlich ist, mit was die Zuschauer angezogen werden
sollen, aber dann, aber dann heißt es immer so nach dem, natürlich, ja, wenn du nicht
wegen dem Game hier bist, dann kannst du auch wieder gehen oder sowas, der ist wenigstens
klar, wie sie die Leute anspricht und tut nicht so, als wärs nicht so, wo auch überhaupt
nichts Verwerfliches dran ist, wie gesagt, ich find das, find das nicht schlimm grundsätzlich,
was war um 19 mit Modern Warfare, es gab nen Stream, wo sie nen neuen Spielmodus gezeigt
haben und wo man zum ersten Mal ein bisschen Gameplay gesehen hat, aber der Spielmodus
war crap, kannst du Usenet mal erklären, das ist doch Vorgänger vom Forum quasi, allerdings
konnte man, oder kann man Binaries auch darüber tauschen, natürlich nur legale Sachen, ja
da sind bestimmt genug, genug 12 und 14 jährige dabei, keine Frage, aber das sind nicht die,
die sich 2000 Euro Snapchat kaufen, das sind die, die, keine Ahnung, ein bisschen Patreon
bezahlen, die irgendwie vielleicht sich den Einsteigertier auf Snapchat kaufen, es bestimmt,
wahrscheinlich ist es in nem gewissen Umfeld und in nem gewissen Alter auch nice, weil
man quasi zeigen kann, ey guck mal hier, ich hab Snapchat, Delfin oder so, aber die 2500
Euro Snapchat Typen, das sind keine 14 jährigen, 2500 Euro von Snapchat Account glaub ich sogar
oder oder Dollar, ich mein, die hat, ich weiß gar nicht ob man die Seite aufmachen dürfen
ohne das jetzt hier gleich Monkathos ist, Patreon, die macht das wirklich sehr geschickt,
ich wünsche mir nicht, dass ich das aufmachen kann, ich lass es mal lieber sein, ey, so hat
man sich das Monkathos angesagt, ey, ich guck mir die Seite mal, ich guck mir die Seite
mal an auf dem anderen Browser, ob das wirklich so schlimm ist, was man da drauf sieht, naja,
also Premium Snapchat gibt's für 50, gibt's für 50 Euro, 50 Dollar im Monat, da könnt
ich mir vorstellen, dass es der eine oder andere mit seinem Taschengeld macht, allerdings
danach geht's ja weiter und das höchste Tier ist halt 2500 im Monat und dafür kriegst
du halt exklusiven, nee, was, nee, sorry ich hab Mist erzählt, ab 1000 Euro im Monat kriegst
du sogar schon Exis zum privaten Snapchat, sorry 2500 war falsch, es sind nur, also
ein Schnapper quasi, nur 1000 Dollar im Monat für den privaten Snapchat Account, das ist
die mit dem Badewasser, ja, gönnt ihr, gönnt euch, ja, ich mach das halt richtig, ich hab
genug, die da sehen wollen und ich mein letztendlich, mal ganz ehrlich, so was wie dieses Gamingwasser,
das nimmt zwar schon irgendwie so ein bisschen groteske Ausmaße an, aber letztendlich, es
geht überhaupt nicht darum, ob das wirklich jemand kauft oder nicht, wenn wir uns die
Google Ergebnisse angucken, von der Suche nach ihr, da könnt ihr wecken, sehen wir,
dass im letzten Monat einfach irgendwie wahrscheinlich 800% mehr gesucht wurde, oh der Cyrus hat
mich gehorstet, danke schön, ich bin zwar quasi gerade auf den Sprung, aber das ist
sehr nett von dir, dass du mich horstest, wir sitzen einfach nur sinnlos hier und wollten
uns eigentlich einen neuen PC zusammenstellen und jetzt schwätzen wir seit gefühlt 1 Stunde
sinnlos rum über Gamer Girl, Badewasser und alles mögliche, ja, ist ja nice, danke, danke
und jetzt hab ich ganz vergessen, wo wir stehen geblieben sind, genau, was ich sagen wollte
ist, es geht ja überhaupt nicht darum, ob irgendjemand sich wirklich Gamer Girl Badewasser
oder sowas holt, ich muss mal gucken, ob wir, man kann doch, man kann bei Google irgendwo
vergleichen, wie ging das nochmal, Suchergebnisse, also wie oft wurde was gesucht im Monat,
und unabhängig davon, ob diesen Kram irgendjemand kauft, es haben definitiv diesen Monat so viele
Leute wie noch nie vorher nach der gesucht, wie ging das hier, Google Trends oder sowas
war das, genau, Google Trends, also gucken wir mal, ja ich weiß, ich hab Bell oder Bälle,
hier Leute, mit sowas sorgst du halt dafür, ja, machs gut Cyrus, mit sowas sorgst du letztendlich
dafür, dass die Leute, dass Leute auf dich kommen, die, keine Ahnung, dass die überhaupt
existiert vorher, ja klar, dass es eben irgendwelche Leute, irgendwelche Verrückte gibt, die das
wirklich kaufen, ok, ja, wundert mich auch nicht letztendlich, es gibt auch Leute, die
2500 Euro Snapchat kaufen, aber selbst wenn es nicht einer gekauft hätte, hätt sich das
doch schon gelohnt, ich mein, das hier war so normal, und das hier ist die, das hier ist
die, die, die Gamer Girl Wassergeschichte, ist doch, ist doch aus ihrer Sicht, das ist
doch perfekt, besser, besser kann es doch eigentlich gar nicht laufen, oder, weltweit einstellen
kann man auch weltweit einstellen, achso, ja, naja, es ist im Prinzip das gleiche, Südkorea,
ok, ich wusste nicht, dass Südkorea da so scharf drauf ist, na gut, ich glaub die macht
viel Cosplay-Kram und sowas, warum nicht, ja, aber allein schon da hat es was gebracht,
Südkorea und Estland, ja, warum auch nicht, ja, tja, und ich weiß gar nicht, wie sind
wir überhaupt auf dieses Thema gekommen, genau, wegen YouTube-Money und sowas, ja klar,
und sowas befindet sich dann halt am oberen Ende des Spektrums, und was ich halt, weiß
ich, hab ich schon gesagt, aber was ich halt ein bisschen unfair finde für alle, die kleiner
sind, und die sich richtig Mühe geben, ist halt, dass du, wenn du ein bisschen kleiner
bist, du musst um jeden Scheiß dich prügeln, ja, du musst um jeden Scheiß kämpfen, so
nach dem Motto, ey, wie siehts aus, eh, wie mal ein Game umsonst, oder mal irgendwie da
ein bisschen was kleines, oder hier mal irgendwas, du musst ein Riesenakt machen, dass du irgendwie
was kriegst, oder die Leute davon überzeugst, dass es sich lohnen könnte, oder überhaupt,
das ist ein Riesenakt, wenn du klein bist, ja, hast ne gewisse Größe, speicheln sie
sich halt alle bei dir ab, ist so, und das ist letztendlich nicht nur YouTube und Gaming
bereich, sondern ist halt überall so, wenn du mal ne gewisse Menge hast, kriegste automatisch
mehr, das find ich ja immer ein bisschen schade für die Kleineren, die sich wirklich
Mühe geben, also nicht für Leute, die so bescheuert machen wie ich, die quasi, eh,
theoretisch 260k an Leute ansprechen könnten, aber nix hochladen, sondern wirklich Leute,
die wollen guten Content produzieren, aber halt noch nicht diesen riesen Durchbruch
hatten, die müssen wirklich um jeden Cent kämpfen, dass sie was kriegen, das nennt
man, glaub ich, kritische Masse in der Medienbranche, ja, das passt gut, ist ein bisschen, ist
ein bisschen so, wie wenn man sich Spielerzahlen MMOs anguckt, du brauchst auch ne kritische
Masse, dass es mehr Leute anzieht, da spielt der Freund, spielt das MMO, der andere spielt
das MMO, da will mal einer zusammenspielen, dann spielt die Freundin noch mit, blablabla,
so ist er auch, von Zinsen lebt dort keiner mehr, ne, von Zinsen lebt dort wirklich keiner
mehr, ich krieg auf meinem Konto, überlegen, 0,02% oder so, ne, von Zinsen lebst du halt
wirklich nicht mehr, aber von Gamer Girl Badewasser kannst du leben, so eigentlich
waren wir übrigens, ursprünglich waren wir bei neuen Ryzen CPUs, und noch, davor waren
wir eigentlich mehr oder weniger fertig mit dem Stream, du hast im letzten Jahr 4,8% Zinsen
bekommen, das ist ganz schön viel, kommt dann immer drauf an, aus was das kommt, ne,
also ich mein, du kannst ohne Probleme 4,8% haben, wenn das, kommt noch ein bisschen auf
das Risiko drum rum an, aber einfach von, ich parke mal irgendwo 50k auf so nem 0815
Tagesgeldkonto oder so, da ist halt mit 4,8% eh nix, ja gut, aber das ist eigentlich überhaupt
nicht mein Thema, also von solchen, also wenns um irgendwie Geld und Geldanlage hab
ich absolut kein Plassen Schimmer, was man auch an der Sache sieht, was ich vorhin erzählt
hab, dass ich mich da seit Jahren mal schon drum kümmern wollte, noch die YouTube-Geschichten
n bisschen anzulegen, aber es immer noch nicht gemacht hab, in AMD, in AMD Aktien könnten
wir investieren, ja, AMD Aktien wären noch mal was, vorausgesetzt natürlich, die bringen
noch mal ne ordentliche Grafikkarte raus, die richtig abgeht, das, das wird mir ja echt
gefallen, ja, das, das fänd ich echt mal wieder nice, wenns ne richtig gute Konkurrenzfähige
Grafikkarte von AMD gebe, im Prinzip so wie sie es mit Ryzen jetzt gemacht haben, oh
schau, ne, das ist ein krasser Shit, ja, und danke für die Donation, ich muss erstmal
in Tippy Stream gucken, 1 Cent für den Max, ja, dann nicht der Mindestbetrag, wat, Moment,
ah, schon wieder der Flow 96, der Flow 96 ist heute aber wirklich äußerst, äußerst
aktiv, was das angeht, und, ja, ich mach auch meinen Twitch-Partner-Antrag jetzt demnächst,
ja, du hast mich, du hast mich ja überzeugt, ich muss das jetzt machen, ich weiß auch
gar nicht, warum ich da, dass wir mal wieder beim Thema sind, dass ich, wenns drum geht,
das irgendwie ordentlich zu verkaufen und Kohle zu machen, dass ich da einfach nichts
ähm, der richtige irgendwie bin, ja, andere hätten wahrscheinlich schon nach dem dritten
Stream gleich mal, gleich mal Partner angemacht, aber, tja, war mir irgendwie nicht, no, Discord
wollten wir uns eigentlich nur angucken, aber das kriegen wir heute nicht mal gebacken,
zumal auch der Sebaro und der Patronik nicht da sind, die bräuchte ich mehr dafür, mein
Bankkaufmann, der mir mein Konto, was, Moment, ein Bankkaufmann, der mir mein Konto eröffnet
hat, meinte, dass so ein Brogger so um die eine Million Euro im Leben verdient, was sagst
du dazu?
Mal hochrechnen, aber so, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass man irgendwie, keine
Ahnung, mit 50, 60k im Jahr, das ist, das ist nicht viel, also das kann auch deutlich
mehr sein, ähm, vor allem wenn du in Regionen wie, sagen wir mal, irgendwie Frankfurt bist
und in einem Bereich, der halt wirklich gefragt ist, also sagen wir mal so irgendwie 50, 60k,
ähm, 60k, 60k, da baste, no, ist schon mehr, gut, du musst auch Steuern bezahlen, ne, aber
insgesamt ist das ein bisschen wenig, kriegst du locker hin, ja, Durchschnitt ist, Durchschnitt
finde ich ist immer so eine Sache, da klar, es spiegelt schon irgendwie die Realität
wieder, sonst wäre es nicht der Durchschnitt, allerdings, wenn wir jetzt mal vom ganz extremen
Fall ausgehen, ja, einer verdient nichts und einer verdient, äh, ultra viel, ist der Durchschnitt
auch die Hälfte davon, also das, das schwankt schon ganz erheblich, je nachdem, was du machst
und was du kannst, was aber auch gut ist, weil ich mein, warum sollte man jemand, der,
ähm, Druckerpatronen tauschen kann, ähnlich, ähnlich, äh, bezahlen wie jemand, der, was
gibt's denn, was gibt's denn schönes, jemand, der Koball programmieren kann, um jetzt mal
ein bisschen was ausgefallenes zu nehmen, ne, jemand, der Druckerpatronen tauschen kann,
das findest du an jeder Ecke, jemand, der, äh, bei Koball durchplägt, findest du so
irgendwie gar nicht, allerdings wird sich das auch erledigt haben die nächsten Jahre
so über, allerdings sagt man das da schon in den letzten 30 Jahren, okay Leute, also,
ich hatte eigentlich überhaupt nicht vor so lang zu streamen, ähm, sobald ich immer
noch krank bin, wahrscheinlich tut mir der Hals morgen wieder weh jetzt, 4 Stunden 15
Minuten, also, ich glaube, ich mach jetzt Schluss, ähm, gucken, jetzt wär's ja los
jetzt, müsste das Cyrus wieder on sein, dann können wir ihn rehosten, ähm, ich guck mal
wer, wer online ist, und, also, ich bin die ganze Woche krank geschrieben, mir geht's
heutz, seit heute eigentlich wieder halbwegs besser, ähm, also, könnte durchaus sein,
dass ich gleich morgen Mittag wieder anfange mit streamen, ja, muss man mal schauen, also,
ich hoffe, ich hat's trotzdem gefallen, und danke an den Cyrus für den host, so, ich
seh keinen, den ich hosten kann von den Leuten, den ich follow, keiner da, ich hoste immer
ungern Leute, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 1500, 2000 und so was Zuschauer haben, die
haben's eigentlich nicht so nötig meistens, ähm, ja, keine Ahnung, gut, ähm, haben wir
Schluss, hosten, es ist jetzt, läuft das immer noch, Starcraft lief doch, das lief doch
seit heute Morgen schon, ähm, Korea-Dings, war das GSL, ich weiß, ich hab ein bisschen
geguckt, Tablet vorhin, so, Leute, Outro, macht's gut, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen,
ähm, wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen, bis denn, macht's gut, see you, vielleicht
soll ich schon ausmachen, ha, das ist die light-Variante von aus, ok, macht's gut, bis
denn.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.